and welcome to the great race 2026.
The mother road will be um our goal and
we'll look forward to seeing you all in
Springfield.
>> You always have
Illinois.
>> Yeah, there's Springfield unless the
Simpsons
>> coming to Springfield, Missouri for the
spring rally,
>> right?
>> Um we are Steven Janet Headki. We are
the rookie coordinator. So, we are the
ones who match rookie teams up with a uh
veteran team to help bring you along and
uh acclimate you to what the grace great
race looks like. And uh hopefully we'll
be doing that over the next two hours.
That's the uh the goal for this call.
And we will um have the chat open at any
time so you can be um putting in your uh
questions along the way. But um save
save live questions till the end if you
would. So on the agenda we're going to
be going through just some uh basic
housekeeping and um then we have our
great race director Brad Phillips on the
line and he's going to make a couple of
announcements and just introduce himself
to you. We'll talk about the rules of
the driver and navigator and uh how to
prepare yourself and your car before you
leave and what will happen when you
arrive in Springfield. There's a lot of
activities that they've planned. and
it's going to be a lot of fun. And then
we'll talk about what the day in the
life of a great racer looks like. And it
will be Groundhog Day for nine straight
days. It will be great fun, but a lot of
work. And you will be very exhausted by
the end in a good way. And then we'll go
through some course instructions to give
you an idea of what they look like and
how to interpret them and how to follow
those. And then there's a new process
for time allowances that we're going to
discuss in detail. We'll talk about some
special circumstances and then we'll be
available to answer your questions. So,
Ken, why don't you get started with some
housekeeping for us.
>> Hi, welcome. This is Ken Spencer and uh
hopefully I can facilitate this for us.
But um uh as we go along, if you have
questions, first of all, you can post
things in the chat and I'll try to get
that to them. There'll be plenty of Q&A
at the at the end if needed. So, write
it down so you don't forget if you have
to. Um, if for some reason you can't
digitally raise your hand, that's
usually uh you go down and you go to uh
the where they've hidden they've hidden
it again and changed it. But you
actually, believe it or not, in some of
them you just raise your hand like that
and it'll it'll do it. But otherwise,
you can go into the uh uh raise hand
control. Um if uh we're going to
probably when it gets started here,
we're going to mute everybody and then
uh if you need to unmute yourself, uh go
for it because otherwise we get chatter
in the background. Uh other than that,
uh Janet has uh done it so it's being
recorded now and that'll be available
after the fact. So, and feel free to ask
any questions about Zoom in there. Uh if
you don't have We've got more waiting
room people. Let's see. I think we are
at a limit of 100 and we keep if
somebody leaves, we're getting another
one in. So, there may be some people
that aren't coming.
>> Oh, wow.
>> I I I think I have up to 500 that I'm
permitted. So, Okay. So, we're good with
that.
>> Seems to be good. Perfect. Well, and uh
just go along. Again, you can ask
specific questions in chat. I'll be
happy to try to get it. If not, we'll
forward it to Janet and Steve. Thank you
again. Go for it.
>> All right. If you'll advance the slide
to uh Brad's lovely mug
>> all the way to the mug is right there.
Houston and Brad.
>> Is this my queue?
>> That is your queue.
>> Cool.
>> All right. Well, it's really nice to see
everybody out here. Um I'm Brad
Phillips. I'm the director of Great
Race. Um I'm the guy in the hat, and you
can also tell from seeing me right here.
and uh Houston Gibson, who many of you
have already spoken to, is there on the
passenger side, that was us in October
on a Northeast Rally Club event. So,
there are regional clubs that do this
sort of thing that and really help feed
into what Great Race and Spring Rally is
all about. So, Houston is our manager of
events and experiences, and he's been
doing this longer than I have. Um, I
came on as as director of Great Race in
October of last year. That's 2025. Prior
to that, my experience has been as a
driver. Um, and I've been doing these
kinds of races since about 2003.
And I've raced uh most notably a 1916
Hudson Speedster that is way above my
pay grade. Um, owned by the Stall
Automotive Foundation and Dan Stall was
the navigator. and I have given all that
up to help run the race, create new
experiences, and really, really, really
just have a great time with everybody.
So, um, I'm super excited to be here.
Um, there are fully onethird of the 150
or so teams that we have running in
Great Race for 2026 on Route 66 are
rookies. So, you have to understand you
were all in good company and Steve and
Janet are the best of the best and all
of our goal is to make you feel
comfortable with the competition to know
that there are three things that you
should do and in this order. You should
have fun and make friends. This is an
unbelievable experience. It's an
absolute bucket list to be able to
participate and compete in something
like this. But above all, have fun. Um,
try not to get lost. If you follow the
instructions, even if you're not exactly
on time, if you're just kind of where
you're supposed to be, you're gonna get
there. It's going to be great. And the
absolute third thing is make sure you're
dead nuts on time all the time. All
these things will grow over time
together. But if you do number one and
two, number three will come much easier,
and the fun will just build and build
over the years. and we hope every one of
you as a rookie is going to come on and
be a sportsman and a veteran with us
over many, many years. So, I don't have
a lot of other comments. I'm proud to be
here. I'm happy to be here and thank you
all so much for trusting in us uh for
such a great time with us on Route 66.
So, Stephen and Janet, I'll I'll give it
back to you.
>> Thanks.
>> So, we're going to first clarify what is
the great race.
It is a time speed endurance precision
driving rally. It's not time speed
distance. It's time speed endurance.
That's for you and the car. It's also an
annual family reunion of a community of
car lovers. It's an opportunity to see
the best of America. We're going to see
some amazing scenic back roads and small
towns. It will be an adventure and you
have the potential to earn awards,
recognition, respect, maybe some cash,
but it is the most fun you can have in
an old car. So, we're going to start out
by defining the roles of the driver and
the navigator, and I will hand that over
to my driver.
>> Hi guys. Um, as a driver,
>> next slide.
The roles of the driver.
Thank you for that because I can read
that easier than
Okay. U you've already heard about the
idea of this time wise speedometer and
holding exact speeds. The idea is that
if you hold your speed and follow the
directions and do the directions in
order, you'll be on time. And the
driver's job, uh people will say that
drivers are stupid. Um, it's not really
true.
It's just that 85% of your concentration
ability is on that speedometer. So, you
want to try to mount it up as high as
you can so with your peripheral vision,
you can see the traffic down the road.
Um, you want to be able to, um, practice
before you get to the race. When you do
your performance chart, which we'll talk
about, you want to drive the car the
same way. And um it doesn't matter how
fast or slow your car is as long as you
accelerate and stop at the same rate of
speed every time so that the navigator's
chart is accurate. Takes some practice,
but after a while you get the feel of
what the car wants to do. And you know,
don't try to do it 100% throttle, 100%
break every time because the car will
break, you won't finish. And to finish
is to win. So, you want to make sure
that you take care of your car to the
best of your ability. Uh, when the
navigator tells you to do something,
don't argue. Uh, the navigator has the
brain power on staying on course. You're
trying to hold the speed. Um, if you're
thinking to yourself, "Well, no, I need
I don't think I'm going as fast as I
should," don't do that. Don't change
anything. let the navigator tell you
what speed you should be driving and
just do that. Um, you want to be able to
look down the road. Um, it's really easy
to get fixated on the speedometer. Um,
and you'll be chasing it. You can get it
what I call a driver induced
oscillation. Too fast, too slow, too
fast, too slow, too fast, too slow.
You're gas brake, gas break. You want to
do it as fluid as possible. If you're
like 3 miles an hour over the speed
limit when you look at the speedometer
or the speed you're supposed to go, go 3
miles an hour below the speed you're
supposed to go for about the same amount
of time you were off and then back to
where you're supposed to be. That's not
something the navigator is going to do.
That's a driver's job. Um, and you can
make those corrections. If the navigator
says you're off by two miles an hour,
you can say, "Yeah, I'm correcting. I'm
going to be be right back to it." Um,
and you want to be able to look down the
road. Sometimes the lane you're in will
disappear and you have to merge to the
left. You don't want to wait till the
last second to do that. You want to be
able to hold your speed as you
transition into a lane. Um so be aware
of what's ahead of you. So if you have
to make maybe a stop that you're not uh
or you're not planning on, um let the
navigator know you're going to have to
stop so the navigator can get the
stopwatch out and time that. you can
warn the navigator ahead of time that
I'm not going to be able to make what
we're supposed to do. Uh, communication,
the way we work it, and other teams do
it differently, she will tell me the
speed I'm supposed to go, I will repeat
the speed, and throughout the time that
I'm holding that speed, I'll
occasionally say, "Okay, I'm holding
35." And she'll confirm that yes, 35 is
what you're supposed to do. Because
again, driver's stupid and it's really
easy to forget by staring at that
speedometer what speed you're supposed
to be going. Um, if you if it creeps off
a little bit, you look at it and go, "Am
I fast or slow? I don't remember the
speed." Okay, what speed? The navigator
needs to know that the driver could be
asking that question repeatedly. Yeah, I
just told you. No, keep telling the
driver the speed they're supposed to go.
It helps the driver. um physical
preparation. This race, if you're on the
Route 66 run for the big race, we've
done this before. And since we live in
California, we know what the desert is
like in the middle of summer. And um it
there was one time that we stopped uh
and no one knows how hot it was because
all the thermometers were pegged at 125.
If your car has a problem with vapor
lock or more importantly you have a
problem with vapor lock, make sure that
you hydrate yourself in the morning
before you're thirsty. You've got to
make sure that your brain is functioning
and sharp and do all those things that
you would be doing if you were going on
a hike, let's say. Um, and uh make sure
that you can get the um
oh, what's the best word for it? Uh if
you know that you have an issue with
something, like if you're taking pills
or you're an old guy like me and there's
things that you have to do to prepare
yourself for sitting for an hour and a
half, um do that ahead of time, you
know, and that'll make it easier for you
to hang in there while you're driving.
And then the most important thing is
that you guys win and lose as a team. U
it's a three-legged stool the way it
used to be described to us. You've got
the car, the driver, and the navigator.
All three have to function correctly in
order to do this well. So if one of you
makes a mistake, the other one has to
just help you correct it. Most of the
time we can fix mistakes and and if you
can't then you throw that leg away, you
get throwaway legs and you go on to the
next one. Don't focus on it and don't
get mad at each other. You have to just
let it drop and keep rallying because
the rally is not over. It's a long event
and uh you know the mistake you make
here two days later doesn't matter
anymore. So try not to get too upset and
and pres you uh preserve the uh
camaraderie within the car as best you
can.
>> Okay, so going on to navigating 101. Um
generally you're going to have a whole
bunch of stuff on your lab. My lap board
looks like this. It's got room. I'm
left-handed, so I have No, I've got it
here. Um, I've got my root instructions
and my order of star
on the left. I've got my clock. It is
hung around my neck, but I have a piece
of um Velcro there so I can just stick
it there so I'm not fumbling around
looking for it. Pens, nav, uh,
highlighters, all that stuff is right in
front of me. Some people prefer to take
their clock and to stick it right in
front of them on the dashboard of the
car. Um, whatever works for you. Uh, but
you want to make sure that you've got a
clock that you can read clearly. Um,
there are a number of different rally
clocks that are available. One of our
great racers, Ron Roland, has uh a
company where he makes these. It's got a
light a movable bezel so it will um keep
track of your um short periods of time
that you're trying to keep track of. Um
so I found that one very uh helpful for
me personally, but you can literally go
to Walmart and get a $10 clock off the
>> off the display and it'll work just fine
for you. You want to make sure it's got
a sweep second hand and preferably the
second hand is as close to the face of
the clock as possible so that you don't
have any parallax. Um but uh you want a
stopwatch that has um time of day as
well as the stopwatch function because
this is a backup um clock for you. So
you've got your time of day clock,
you've got your stopwatch, and you may
not use your um Apple Watch. It has to
be uh an analog uh wristwatch. The
driver may have one, the navigator may
have one, but nothing with any advanced
electronic functions on it. So, um your
performance chart is something that you
should all be working on to create. Um
ours has lots and lots and lots of
numbers on it. Um we will talk to you uh
a little further down in the
presentation about how to create one.
And there's a great tool that one of our
racers has created that can help you to
do that. Um, your best friend is the
start order. They will give you this
every day and it will list all of the
participants, what time the race starts
uh, for that day, what order the cars
are in. And so you'll see who you
follow, who's behind you. If you happen
to get lost, you're going to be looking
at this to see how to get back uh
yourself back in order from where you
started. So, start order is critical to
have at your uh
right close to uh close to hand. And
then, of course, your root instructions
that you'll get every day. So, those are
your key uh tools that you're going to
use as a navigator.
>> Okay. the under root instructions.
>> Under root instructions, your root
instructions
on the next slide start out looking nice
and clean and pretty. By the end of the
day, they aren't. And uh we're going to
go through those uh turn by turn at the
end. We've got a sample route
instruction uh to follow. And so we will
explain what each one of these little
hieroglyphics
mean and uh how to navigate those. Each
day uh when we start, we have a rally
school at the beginning and the director
of competition will go through all of
the instructions that you're going to
see when you go out on your very first
rally. So, he will have gone through
step by step, show you which ones they
are before you get out on the course for
the first time.
Okay. So, another key thing that you
need to work uh work on as a team is
your communication. So, on the next
slide, uh just to give you some
examples, you're going to be coming
across a lot of road signs that look
like this, some that don't even look as
normal as that. And you'll need to be
able to describe as the navigator to
your driver what it is that you're
looking for. Um some of these will have
a mileage uh number underneath it. So,
it might be a right curve 35. Some
people might call this a easy right turn
um or a curve warning sign. Um but but
basically, you just want to to determine
what it is that you're going to call
them so that your driver knows what it
is that you're talking about. So, you
have what we call a right curve, a hard
left curve. Some people may call that a
dead man curve or a 90deree curve. Um
the next one side road to the left. Um
the following one we call a stairst
step. Some people may call a chair. Some
people may call a double dead man.
Whatever it is that you call it, make
sure that you understand um what what uh
your terminology is going to be so that
you're communicating well in that. Um
the next one is a either a snake or a
squiggle. um left. There's actually two
different ones. That one is a left
snake. There's also a right snake where
the U arrow is pointing the opposite
direction, but as far as we're
concerned, it's a squiggle. But make
sure that you have that consistent
terminology that you're using between
the two of you.
>> And that's something you can do when
you're out working on your performance
chart before you get to the race.
>> Okay, Ken.
>> All right. So Steve's going to tell you
about a lot of things that you're going
to need to do to prepare yourself and
your car before you leave.
>> One of the things about Great Race is
that you're basically on the clock until
you leave the awards dinner and you're
on your way home. Uh you're thinking
about how long it's going to take you to
get to the start. Uh when you have to do
maintenance or repairs on the car when
you get it back in time to get it ready
to go to the race. um you're thinking in
terms of um how much my car for example
tires almost everybody makes sure that
they have new or as new tires from Coker
tire uh on their car uh just so they
don't have to worry about punctures
because if you have a flat tire while
you're on the race you're going to be
late by however many minutes it takes
you to change your tire. So almost
everybody runs fresh tires. They don't
they never get close to 20,000 miles. Um
the uh stuff that you carry in the car
with you. Um if you're a mechanic and
you can work on your own car, service
it, uh I recommend that you only bring
the uh the stuff that you need that you
can repair on the side of the road. You
know, don't carry a spare engine in the
trunk. It won't help you. Um but if you
know, if you water, oil, um
I usually bring uh a tire inflator can
if that will get me back on the road
quickly. Um you have basic tools. Uh
something to diagnose electrical stuff
with like a simple probe. Um a lot of
guys carry a jump box. Uh I found that
useful from time to time. U brake fluid
uh just in case you don't want to have
that be a problem. Uh the uh the list
depends on you and your car. Uh what
you're capable of doing on the side of
the road. Um remember that um the uh
sweep truck will be coming along. If the
car is just broken, you know, you get it
out of the way of your other competitors
that are coming by. And at the end,
Steve and Vicki will come by and let the
truck know where you are. and uh the
truck will come by and pick you up,
bring you in uh to the hotel at the end
of the day and then you have if you can
all night fix it uh almost every night
out in the hotel parking lot there are
folks working on their car to get it
ready for the next day. Uh some of the
competitors will have a similar car to
yours. They may have a spare part that
they have that you don't have. If you
have a support crew, you're not going to
be able to contact them until you're off
the clock. But if you're on the sweep
truck, you can take your cell phone and
call your support crew and say, "Hey,
you know, I need one of these. You know,
stop by O'Reilly's and pick one up for
me and I can install it in the parking
lot." Uh there's a lot of that that goes
on. All the folks around you will be
happy to help you. And then um the Do
you want to talk about performance chart
here?
>> Not yet.
>> Oh, okay. Because it says performance
chart. Yeah. the uh decal application.
Uh in the past, the race has sent out
decals uh in advance in spring. You can
correct me, Brad, if I got this wrong,
but the uh when we go to Springfield uh
for the regional race, they may give you
the stickers for the big race if you're
doing both. Uh but there's an absolute
order to put the decals on. Go ahead.
Okay. There's a there's a an order that
the decals go in. Just like in NASCAR,
there's a particular position that the
sponsor has paid to put the sticker on
your car. If you got a really nice paint
job, make sure you got a good wax job on
it because these stickers can get pretty
sticky. And there's, you know, you can
get them off with a heat gun, but uh if
you have a a really nice paint job,
you're going to be putting the stickers
on anyway. You have to have the stickers
on to get through tech. Anything
else?
>> Um, no.
>> If you've run the race uh before and
you've got old sponsor stickers that are
no longer sponsors, they will ask you to
remove those. So, they'll be very uh
careful about which decals you're
allowed to have on your car, which
you're not. Uh for those who have run
the race multiple times, um those little
ace stickers that you get for for
perfect uh arrival at a checkpoint, um
people have 20, 30 years worth of ace
stickers all over their cars. You can't
even see what color the car is anymore.
But um you have the option to keep your
A stickers on as long as you want to.
>> And that's all in the
the rule book as well. Will tell you all
that stuff.
>> All right. On to your speedometer
calibration. Okay. Um, speedometer
calibration. This is the first uh
performance thing you do every day and
you do it every day. The you would think
that 35 is 30 or 50 is 50 no matter what
happens. But there are variations from
day to day where the director of
competition may have done something or
not. But we have had times when we
thought our speedometer was right on and
then the next day it's fractionally off.
So every every the first thing we do
once we get out onto the course is a
calibration run and the uh are we
talking installing the instrument?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So if you have a time wise
and it looks like this. Now everybody
should have theirs by now. If you don't,
Jack still has some. He can get you one
pretty quickly, but it's very important
to have a speedometer that you can
calibrate. You'll need to do it every
day. The instructions are real simple.
On the back, you'll see four little
holes back there. There are four wheels
in there to do a fine tuning on your
speed. And uh we will run like on a
fourlane highway run at steady 50 m an
hour road sign on the right uh will be
in your route instructions. That's where
you start your calibration.
>> We'll talk about that later. So right
now we're talking about installing it.
>> Okay. So when you install the time
lights, you need to be able to take it
out so that you can get to the back of
it to adjust those wheels on the back.
So, don't mount it in the dash and make
something real pretty because you're
going to have to take it out at least
once a day. Um, so most of us like to
have it up high on the dashboard where
your peripheral vision has the
speedometer right in it. Makes it you
don't want to be looking over to the
center or down below where the
speedometer is. You want to keep it
somewhere in your line of sight so you
you can drive and watch the speedometer
at the same time. the uh power source
for the speedometer. Some people like to
hook it up to a separate battery that is
not uh in the circuit on the car. Some
cars will produce an electromagnetic
pulse which will throw the speedometer
off in which case you want a dedicated
like motorcycle or tractor battery to
power your speedometer. You just have to
remember that every night when you get
in to take your battery up to your room
and charge it for the next day and hook
it back up. We have it hooked up to our
vehicle's electrical system so it comes
on with the key. That way I don't forget
about the battery. Um the trick with
that is that you don't want to turn the
car off while it's still rolling because
whatever speed you're showing on the
speedometer when you turn it off, that's
where it's going to be. And you could be
at a restart and look at it and say,
"It's saying seven miles an hour and
we're supposed to be at zero." And then
you have to recalibrate it by unscrewing
the face of the speedometer and moving
the needle back to zero. And that can be
uh
>> it takes a long time.
>> It takes longer than you want. um the
initial calibrations in the instructions
for the instrument or you can go on the
Timewise website and look it up. But you
measure five rotations of the wheel on
the ground by you doing a chalk line or
a chalk mark. The total inches to the
nearest tenth as you can is your factor
to enter on the back of your time using
the small screwdriver. test the dials
the mark the top and bottom of the
backside of a speedometer. Ask me why. I
once had the speedometer upside down
>> like this.
>> It you can't tell sometimes. So, uh you
want to make sure you have it right side
up when you put in your calibration or
you'll go way the wrong direction and
that'll be evident right away. Um but
every day you're going to be doing your
speedo calibration run. You're going to
pull out the speedometer, turn it
around, tell the navigator what the
numbers say in the back. She'll say,
"Oh, we're running fast. We're running
slow. We're going to make the adjustment
and give you the number." I have a
little flashlight that I use I stick in
my mouth so I can read the numbers
clearly on the inside. Sometimes it's
hard. The numbers are small for an old
guy with glasses. So, you want to be
able to make sure that you have those
numbers exactly right. read them back a
couple of times so you're both uh
convinced that you've got the right
number in the back of the speedometer.
And if you do it correctly, that thing's
going to be dead accurate all day long.
And anything any variation from uh top
performance is going to be your ability
to hold the speed. So when you do your
speedometer calibration each day during
the race, you'll be following that
course and at the end of the
calibration, which may be 35 minutes, 40
minutes of driving at a consistent
speed, you will know how many seconds
early or late you are at the end of that
um time period. And then what you need
to do is to convert that into clicks to
adjust your speedometer.
And um by dividing your speedometer
factor by 3600.
Our speedometer factor right now is
4057.
And if I divide that by 3600, that gives
me something like 1.13.
So that tells me for every second I am
off, I'm going to change it basically
one click. But once it gets up to like 9
seconds, then I'm going to make it 10
clicks. So that will let me know um how
to adjust that correctly. At the very
very beginning before you actually on
the clock I use my calculator and so you
can do that as long as you're not
actually on the clock. So you can make
it very very accurate by converting the
um actual time to uh to the correct time
and then multiplying that times the
factor that'll give you your new factor.
So, you can do that when you're first
running your calibration when you get to
uh to the race event, but you can't do
it when you're on the clock. You've got
to do it manually on on the clock.
>> And one more thing about setting up the
speedometer, it uses a magnetic pulse.
We put magnets on the left front wheel
because that's the closest to the center
line of the road and more closely
matches what the director of competition
has laid out when they did the route.
Everybody does it on the left front
wheel. Uh you'll you'll put a bracket or
something that will hold the probe close
to the magnet and um try to keep it away
from any heat sources. Uh the magnets
are held on by just plain old JB Weld.
And the magnets you can get at uh
hardware store like Lowe's or Home Depot
actually have the magnets that we use in
stock. And uh you put magnets on the
spare as well.
uh just in case you have to change that
tire. Ask me how I know about that. And
um some pe some people will put magnets
on all the wheels in case you have to
rotate the tires around due to abnormal
wear.
>> Um and Andy to answer your question,
what is the daily calibration like? We
will go through the sample course
instruction at the end and and that will
show you what that process looks like.
>> It's very straightforward.
>> It's easy. Really easy. All right, let's
go on to how to create a performance
chart. This is critical. You must have a
performance chart. And what this will
will do is this will tell you how many
seconds or portions of a second you lose
by doing certain maneuvers. You will uh
the way that the rate the course is set
up, it assumes that you will go from
zero to the assigned speed immediately
or from the assigned speed to zero
immediately at a stop. It assumes that
you will make turns at speed without
having to break slow down at the turns.
So, you know that through the course of
your normal driving, you're going to be
um not not able to live up to that uh
that ideal. So, you will lose a few
seconds by accelerating, by
decelerating, by turning. And your chart
that you will create will um let you
know at all the various speeds how many
seconds or part portions of seconds that
you lose by making those um those
maneuvers and that will be different for
every individual car, every individual
person based on the performance of your
car and how your driver drives it. The
important thing is that your driver
needs to drive it consistently.
consistent acceleration, consistent
braking, consistent turning. Uh we
recommend that you find a uh when you're
making a turn that you hit an exact
speed at the apex every time. We
recommend 15 miles an hour at the apex
of every turn. That way you can practice
that consistency as you're creating your
chart. So to start your chart, you just
start from from scratch. You're going to
find a long straight road, level with
little or no traffic. You want to be
able to turn around safely at both ends.
You're just going to mark a cone or um
uh
>> telephone
>> telephone pole um
>> whatever whatever works for your
beginning and ending point. You want to
be able to enter that um that course at
up to 55 miles an hour and exit it at 50
mile 55 miles an hour without um
any
>> going through the stop sign. Yeah.
>> Okay. So you you you just set up a start
and an ending point and and you're going
to be doing that at all of those speeds
from 10 to 55 miles an hour. It will
take you hours. It will take hours. to
plan on just setting aside a Saturday
and just going out and doing it. Um, so
you mark each end of the course and then
you run the course at speed. So entering
your start point at speed. So say you're
doing 30 m an hour, 30 m an hour,
entering it, hit your stopwatch and then
as you exit it, hit the stopwatch again.
That is your base. So at speed, you know
it takes that long to run that course.
go back to the beginning at a stop,
run the course again,
get up to that 30 miles an hour, hit the
stopwatch at the end. The difference
between those two is your acceleration
loss.
So, it's not the elapsed time that it
takes you to get to 30 miles an hour.
It's the difference in time between
accelerating to speed or already being
at speed. And you're going to do that
for every one of those speeds from 10 to
55. 55 is new this year.
And I recommend that you do it several
times and then average each one of
those. And so you'll have basically an
an average of all of those numbers.
Once you have that um then you're going
to do the next step which in our case go
on to the next slide Ken
is um a stop and go. So you've already
got the acceleration. What we do is we
enter at speed and then we stop and
immediately start again. Get back to
speed, stop and start again. Get back up
to speed, stop and start again. So, if
I've got three
stop and goes, I'm going to average
those
and I will know now how um what the the
length of time is that I've lost for a
stop and go. I already know what my time
is for the go for the acceleration. If I
just sub subtract that from the stop and
go, now I've got the answer for my
deceleration for stopping.
Now, other people have done this in a
different way. Um,
if you Let's flip to the next screen
real quick. Ken, um, one of our racers,
Brandon Greg, who is amazing, has
created this chart. This was linked in
the weekly newsletter number 32.
And what he recommends is that you go
through the entire course at speed and
stop at the end. Well, you're going to
have to do that three times as long than
doing it my way. But that's uh that's an
alternative. So there's there's
different ways to do that. But um I like
to have the stopand go number because
sometimes you'll encounter that on on
the road. There might be a car that's
turning in front of you. It's like we're
going to do a stop and go. Okay, stop
and go. And then you're back up to speed
and I know exactly how many seconds
we've lost at stop and go because I've
got that number on my chart.
>> Let me throw something in here real
quick as a driver as you're doing this.
the uh just to be clear on your visual
picture of how setting up a chart works.
You're not so concerned about the amount
of distance between the two markers that
you're using to set up your chart except
for the ability to stop after you pass
the last one at 55. You need some runoff
room and you need to be able to turn
around and go back and do it the other
direction.
the um the driver
tends to stop more quickly than you
accelerate. Um that's okay as long as
you do it the same way every time.
Doing the chart this way tells you it it
it builds into the factor how the driver
is driving. As long as you're
consistent, the amount of time for a
stop and go will be the same every time.
We use a technique when we stop is when
the car comes, you know, pitches down
and then when it rolls back again,
that's when she hits the stopwatch.
That's how you know that's where you
have stopped. Um, that's it works for
us. Uh, other cars may be different, but
the the driver's role in creating the
performance chart is that you got to you
have to drive it the same way all the
time. If you're starting like on a hill,
let's say that on the on the course, uh,
you know that you're pulling out at like
30 miles an hour and you've got a slight
grade that you're going up. That may
slow you down if you haven't practiced
that. The driver will anticipate that
while she's counting down 3, two, one, I
may lift up on the clutch at one and go
just because I'm anticipating it's going
to be a little slower going up the hill.
That's not something you can really
calculate because it's going to be
different every time you do it. But the
driver can look at this and say, "Hey,
this is downhill. I'm going to be going
a lot faster up to my speed than I
normally would. So, I won't accelerate
quite as hard." If that makes sense to
everybody.
Okay, just uh if you back up one slide
real quick, Ken, uh the third thing that
you want to have on your chart is turns.
And again, you want to be consistent um
in breaking to that same um speed at
every turn. Again, we recommend 15. Um
so, as you're going through your course,
you don't have a turn on your course,
but what you can do is I'll say, "Okay,
go down to 15." You'll go down to 15 and
then accelerate back up. and you're back
at speed down to 15 and then speed up
again back to speed. And so you'll
average those just like you did the stop
and goes and that will give you your
turn numbers for your chart.
All right, let's go on to um again this
is the um
the
tool that that Brandon has created. I
highly recommend it. It's very very well
done. It will create a very good quality
chart for you. So follow his directions,
follow what I just told you and you'll
end up with a chart that will be very
good for you. So you can see in our next
slide, we started with something very
simple in our olden days and our chart
now is it's more and more complicated
every year, but you really don't need
anything more than the one on your left,
except it should go up to 55 instead of
50 now. Okay, next slide.
Uh, support crews are a fabulous thing.
If you have the ability to have a
support crew, it will lighten your load
an amazing amount, but you can do the
race on your own. You don't have to have
a support crew. Um, what they uh what
they do is is if you bring your car by
trailer, they're going to be driving
your truck and trailer from overnight
stop to overnight stop. They may be uh
checking you into your hotel. They may
be shleing your luggage around. They may
be running errands for you. They may
even do your laundry if they're really
nice. Like if it's your mom and dad. Um
they have great race credentials. They
can attend all of the official
activities except they can't be on the
race route. So they won't be at the
hosted lunches, but they will be there
at the overnights. Um and they're just
it's it's a marvelous thing if that's
something that works for your team for
your financial situation. it it you know
basically you're doubling the cost of
gas in hotels by having a support crew.
Um and so you just kind of have to work
with them. It's like okay we will cover
this if you'll cover this. Um but um and
and it's sharing the the excitement of
the race with someone who um maybe would
be interested in a future year of doing
that. We just happen to have a a rookie
team that we are mentoring who were our
support crew a couple of years ago that
just loved the race and now they're
doing it themselves. So
>> now we don't have a support crew.
>> So the other thing is that if you're
running the regional race, you don't
need the support crew. Um you there'll
be a place to park your truck and
trailer at the hotel. It'll be out and
back to the same hotel each night and
you won't be putting your car back on
the trailer until you're done. So, you
don't need one for the regional. Uh, for
the big race where you're traveling
2,000 miles and your car doesn't hold
enough luggage for you to have a clean
shirt every day, the support crew can
help. Or if, like Janet said, if you can
get somebody who can share support crew
duties, uh, somebody who can take a
suitcase for you, for example, you can
work that out, too. There are support
crew instructions, like Janet said. And
on the big race this year, they're going
to have several stops for support crews
that the racers aren't going to be able
to do. Uh, which is really great. The
support crews get to know each other and
they start to have fun. And, uh, uh, so
the support crew job is, uh, not a
thankless one actually. You know, you
get to go along on the deal and you get
to go places and see things that the
racers aren't going to.
>> Yeah. And they can check into the hotel
early and take a nap before we get
there.
Okay, going on to what to pack.
Um, expect all kinds of weather again on
Route 66. It's going to be hot. It's
going to be dry, but we have had
thunderstorms. We've had hot and humid.
We have driven through snow on the Great
Race. Probably not going to happen this
year, but you can expect cold. You can
expect rain. There's always rain on the
Great Race somewhere. If you've got an
open car, you're going to get wet.
People ask you, "What do you do when it
rains?" We get wet. Um, but you'll want
sun protection. You'll want a, you know,
a hat with a wide brim. Um, make sure
you've got drinking water in a cooler
inside your car. Replenish it every day.
It's not going to help you if it's in
the trunk. Um, digital camera. You
cannot use your cell phone when you're
on the clock. And your navigator is
going to want to take pictures of some
of these really cool places, especially
if you're holding speed for like two 2
minutes and 24 seconds. just like I got
nothing to do for 2 minutes and 24
seconds
>> and the driver doesn't get to see
anything. You don't get to see any of
the sightseeing.
>> So I show him at the end of the day look
where we were. Um so make sure you've
got a digital camera if that's something
that's important to you. Um
>> there was a question about GoPros and
X360s. Um my understanding was that it
depends as long as it does not have a
clock on it and you don't have to
activate it with your iPhone.
I believe that is correct because we
have we've had a number of racers that
have used GoPros in the past
>> and I'm not sure about whether or not
you can you can transmit live. Uh you
may be able to record and and post it
later, but I'd have to talk to Brad and
Houston to see if it's okay to run a
live feed from your car. We tried to do
that in the past and it was not
considered something they wanted you to
do. But times have changed and
everybody's, you know, looking for
content and uh we need to check on that
and make sure that uh if you're trying
to do a live feed that that's okay.
>> I I'm This is Brad. I'm That's not a
problem. Um it's just really the
bandwidth. We drive in a lot of places
where it's just you and mobile homes and
chickens running across the road to stay
away from the population. So, where you
may want to live stream, you may not
have signal a lot of times. Um, our rule
is yes, cell phones need to stay hidden
uh in the back of the car. If you've got
a GoPro that will talk wirelessly back
to that device that is not in your reach
without your intervention, no big deal.
But we can certainly talk.
>> And headsets for communication.
Absolutely. Highly recommend them.
Especially if you're in an open car.
>> They just can't be connected to a radio
where you can talk to somebody else
through the heads. It's like an aviation
headset where you have a uh a box under
the dash where you just plug in both
headsets and controls the volume. You're
just talking to each other. Nothing that
communicates outside of that.
>> And then I'm not yelling at him and he's
not saying, "What? What? What?"
>> With an open car, it makes a big
difference. It reduces the amount of
roar that you get from the wind going by
and you're not yelling at each other so
much. You actually understand what each
other says. If you have an open car, we
highly recommend running an aviation
headset combination. Go to Sporty's
Pilot Shop online, buy two headsets and
the uh the box that goes with them.
Usually, they have a 9volt battery in
them. They don't connect to the
vehicle's electrical system, so you can
take them on or off your car without a
problem.
>> Dan and I have run a set for years that
is Bluetooth, and it will only talk to
each other. It does not talk to anything
else. So, you sync them to each other
and we talk Bluetooth. So, that's
available. No wires.
>> Yeah, they've had that out there for
years. So, there's a lot of
>> Well, we had we had oldfashioned ones
when we ran the model.
>> I used to be a pilot. I had headsets.
>> Um, okay. Just getting back to our
slides. Um, Google glasses. I'll let
somebody else discuss that um because
I'm old. Great race sells merchandise.
You're going to get a free shirt. You're
going to get a free hat. there's going
to be other shirts that you're going to
want to buy because they're really cool
and so pack less than you'll think
you'll need. And sometimes you'll go in
uh to the uh host town at the end of the
day, they'll give you a goodie bag and
there will be a t-shirt for their good
for their uh their city in there. So,
you just never know. So, pack less than
you think you'll need. Um, lots of stops
at gas stations with mini marts, a lot
of Walmarts and auto parts stores um
near the the lunch and overnight stops.
So, um, if you need to stop and pick up
stuff, don't feel like you need to pack
everything. You'll have the opportunity
to to pick up uh essentials along the
way. And Steve already talked about what
uh what to pack as far as car parts.
All right, let's see what happens when
we get to Springfield.
There's a lot of cool stuff that's going
to be happening. Um, basically most
teams will be arriving on Wednesday and
that'll be a good time for you to meet
with your mentors. Um, and there's some
optional sightseeing that they've
arranged and so you'll be able to drive
up to Chicago to see the uh the eastern
terminus of Route 66. the American
Giants Museum that has all of those huge
um
statues of, you know, the the guy
holding the tires and and Superman.
>> Yeah. Yeah. The muffler man.
>> Yeah. And uh the Lincoln Tomb. Um
there's going to be an open house on
Wednesday at the Oakland uh Poke Oakland
Antiac uh Pontiac Oakland.
>> Funny because Brad the director now
>> there's a there's a museum that's gonna
have an open house for us
>> and it's a nice one. It's worth going
to.
>> It is. Um, and yes, are you allowed to
put a sticker with your team name on
your car? You better.
Um, okay. Registration and vehicle
inspection will be on Thursday. That
will be according to a schedule.
Literally, it will be minute by minute.
So, there will be 8:00, 801, 802, 803.
Be in line, be on time, be early. Um,
you'll you'll pick up your shirts and
hats. Uh, make sure that you've signed
all the waiverss that need to be signed.
Um there will be merchandise to buy and
then they will give you your u measured
mile speedometer calibration so you can
go out and uh and run that. Um Steve and
I will be available in a meeting room in
the Double Tree Hotel to answer all of
your questions. Um the scoring staff
will be there talking about the time
allowance procedures which we're going
to talk about in a minute. And then
you'll have the opportunity to just chat
with all of your fellow racers. That's
on Thursday. Friday is when it gets
interesting.
Rally school, it's a mandatory meeting.
You're going to see 500 people packed
into the same room and you're going to
look around and go, "Whoa, what did I
get myself into? This is awesome."
So, director of competition John Classen
is a legend in Great Race. Um, he is a
grand champion. He is one of the best
rally masters out there. and he is going
to explain how his route instructions
work and he will go through the trophy
run step by step by step and explain how
that route works and then he will
dismiss uh the veteran teams. The
rookies are going to hang around for
another hour or so and Steve and I will
go into that in even more detail um to
make sure that you are all ready to go
for the trophy run practice rally. It's
um a little bit more than a half of day
rally. You'll just be coming back to the
hotel at the end of the night. Then
there will be an official welcome
dinner. There will be awards
presentations
and then Saturday the race begins. So we
will all get in race order, drive to the
uh old state capital. They will stage us
and we'll hang around there for three
hours. There will be hundreds, hopefully
thousands of spectators there to take
pictures and and just enjoy the ambiance
of of the whole thing. Uh opening
ceremony, official start, a big green
flag waving all over and um Brad will be
up there grinning from ear to ear. Um
and then we will do our our first day of
official rallying. And then at the end
of the day, there will be a what am I
doing wrong seminar and so Steve and I
will be sitting in a conference room
somewhere um answering your questions.
So that will be your first couple days
in Springfield.
Now let's see what's going to happen
after that. A day in the life. Steve,
I'll let you take this over.
>> Oh, okay. Um
there we go.
glasses will only focus so far. Um,
you're given an order of start,
um, which will tell you, um, where
you're going to be in the field, which
changes each day. If there's a you draw
a number out of a hat, that determines
your position. So, if you've been
following this car yesterday, you may
not be following that car today. So, you
want to know the car that you're
following so that when you go to stage
yourself and know where you're supposed
to be for the start, you can verify it
by knowing the cars that are in front of
you and the ones that are behind you and
you put yourself in the middle of that.
Um the uh
the
official start of a rally does not
happen at the hotel. It doesn't happen
on the speedo calibration run. They take
you out into the countryside where we
have some hopefully very quiet two-lane
roads and then there'll be like a sign
on the side of the road that says speed
limit 35 and that could be the official
start. So you are going to be leaving
that sign
when you figure out your start position
and knowing that the race starts they
give the race start time. It starts at
one minute. Doesn't start at zero. First
car at the one minute mark. And then you
look at the cars around you. You watch
the cars in front. As a rookie, you're
going to say, "Okay, this guy should
leave at 5 minutes. This guy leaves at
four. This guy leave at three. This guy
leaves at two. We leave here." You'll
already know where you should be. And
that's the first time you're going to be
using your performance chart. If it says
speed limit 35, you know, you can't go,
you don't start at zero, right on the
time. You have to leave early. So, if it
takes you 15 seconds, let's say, to get
to 30 miles an hour, very slow car, you
know, you, you know, you're going to
have to leave 15 seconds before your
official start time. Hope that is clear.
Do not leave when it says this is your
start time. You have to leave earlier
than your start time. and and we'll
we'll go over that when we do go through
the sample of course instructions.
>> We'll be covering this a couple of more
times,
>> but first first I want to prepare you
before your day starts is is what what
you're going to be moving up to. You
will know you'll know what the race
start time is. So it'll say right at the
top stage start time 8:00. You'll know
your starting position that so say for
example your car number 30. So, you pick
up your route instructions 30 minutes
before your start time. So, if it was
8:00 and work our number 30, we're going
to pick up our instructions at 8:00
because that's 30 minutes before our
start time of 8:00 + 30. So, that's when
we pick up our root instructions.
So, you're going to determine what your
start time is the night before. So,
you're doing all of this backwards. What
time do I need to get up? What time do I
need to have breakfast? What time do I
need to check out of the hotel? When do
I give my suitcases to my support crew
or pack them in the back of my car? You
want to make sure you've got time when
you pick up your instructions to set
your clock and your stopwatch. That's
what you can see in the pictures here.
Uh the top picture, they're picking up
the route instructions. The bottom
picture, they're setting their clocks
and stopwatch at a vehicle that is
parked right next to where you pick up
your instructions. So, that's all part
of your preparation for the day. Pick up
your course instructions. There may be
emergency instructions. There's a team
that goes out a day ahead to run the
next day's route to make sure that there
aren't any road closures or construction
or flooding. Um, and so they may have to
reroute the race or there may be a a
speed that's unsafe because of the road
condition and they may change that. So,
watch for those emergency instructions
because if you don't follow those, then
you're going to mess up your day. As a
driver, I'm primarily watching my
navigator do all this. I'm just waiting
to get in the car and go. Um, that might
be different on your team. The driver
may be taking those responsibilities.
Uh, but the navigator in this case lets
me know uh when we're going to leave.
She's going to be marking her
instructions uh before we get into the
car. So, I'm kind of hanging out with
the other drivers, waiting for our
navigators to finish the prep before the
day starts.
>> And so, you can you can take a few
minutes because you're picking them up
30 minutes before you leave. Um, you'll
have some time to go through and just
make sure that you've got all the pages
that they're um they hand it to you in a
stapled packet. You want to make sure
just in case that all the pages are
there in order. And then um you're just
going to be looking to see, okay, looks
like we've got a maze here. Looks like
there's a train. Uh we're going to be
crossing a railroad track here. Um looks
like there's a a a tricky signal in a
small town. So just kind of preparing
yourself um for what's to come. So
>> before the car pulls out of the parking.
>> All right. So next slide.
Now you're on the road. So, you leave
your hotel within the 30 minute window
after you've picked up your
instructions. Then you'll do a
speedometer calibration run and we will
show you how that works in the route
instructions and uh figure out what to
do with the result. It's going to tell
you you're either on time or you're
early or late. What do you do with that
once you know what it is? And see that
top picture? That's a checkpoint. We're
probably going to see something that
looks very much like that. very very
very long straight road through a desert
in this could be Nevada, this could be
um Arizona, this could be California,
this could be New Mexico. It looks a lot
like that. And your next instruction is
probably a hard right turn. So, you know
you're going to be going that speed for
a really long time.
>> Navigator gets to take a break. The
driver is trying hard to stay awake
while holding 50 mph
>> or 55 or 48. 48 is something that you'll
see on on quite a few occasions. Um,
okay. So, you've done your speedometer
calibration. That start point again,
it's in in the middle of nowhere, and
you're just going to be looking at your
order of start to make sure that you are
starting exactly a minute behind the car
in front of you at the speed that you're
supposed to go to, leaving a couple of
seconds early based on your acceleration
loss. Um, there will be checkpoints.
There will be fuel and restroom stops
along the course every day. They will
take you off the clock for that, but in
a very controlled fashion. We'll show
you how that works. There will be a
lunch stop where you will be completely
off the clock for between 45 minutes and
an hour, probably closer to 45 minutes.
Then there will be more instructions,
more checkpoints, more rest stops. And
then once you get to the end of the day,
um actually the the end of the time
section before lunch and the end of the
time section at the end of the day, you
will submit time delays on an app on
your phone. So your phone will be in
your car but out of your reach. It'll be
locked up in your trunk or whatever it
is that um that will keep it away from
you having immediate access to it while
you're driving. You'll pull that out
your clock. You'll submit those time
delays. Go through the finish gate.
There will be a um the announcers will
be there. They'll announce your car.
There will be loud cheering and and and
it's like, "Wow, this is cool. I am a
celebrity and I've never been a
celebrity before in my life. It's really
fun."
And then you will park your cars for a
couple of hours to let the uh the local
uh spectators enjoy them. They will
provide a meal for us and um just enjoy
the time with our racing family and uh
separate instructions for support crews
and um
>> not everybody is staying in the same
hotel. Uh usually there are two or three
hotels depending on the size of the town
and how there's like 4 to 500 people
when you include the support crews that
are traveling on Great Race. So you need
a lot of hotel rooms
>> and the staff
>> and the staff and the um
>> and you'll do this every day in a row
for nine days.
>> So there's there's two car shows a day
basically, one for lunch and one for the
evening. and you are required to leave
your car in the park for May for as long
as they tell you you should because
they've made this arrangement with the
town, they may be providing us dinner.
In return, we're giving them a car show
with 130 cars for two hours. So, if you
have to leave because your car is broken
and you need to get someplace to get it
repaired, talk to Brad.
>> Yeah. Talk to Brad and if he approves
it, you can. Uh, don't leave because he
left. You know, he's going early. I want
to go home early so I can go to bed
early. No, that's not how it works.
You're still on the clock when you're in
the park for me after the competition
for the day is over. All right. Now, the
next thing is very important and it's
not talked about enough and Steve is
really good at this. We're going to talk
about etiquette.
Great race etiquette. You got 130 people
from literally all over the world.
You've got some Japanese guys that don't
really speak English. You've got teams
from England. You've got people from
>> Switzerland and Canada.
>> Yeah. People from New York that drive
differently than people from California,
>> which is good.
>> Yeah, let's put it that way. Um, not
everybody
handles the stress of great race the
same. So, one of the things that you
want to be aware of is that it's just
the game. We're playing a game. You
know, if the game doesn't go well, oh
well, you got tomorrow, you know, go
back to it. You gota, when you come
across the finish line, you've got all
these spectators out there waiting for
you to cross. They may come to you with
asking for an autograph or asking
questions about how the race works. You
know, what's that thing that tachometer
on your dashboard? What's that for? You
know, well, that's a speedometer and
this is how it works. You try to take as
much time with these folks as you can.
uh remembering that if they don't come,
we don't have a race. So, you want to be
like a NASCAR driver. You want to be
able if the guy comes up and sticks a
microphone in your face and say, "Tell
me about this deal." You smile and you
do the best job you can. Uh it's part of
the event. Um and fans will wave wave
back. You know, even if you had a crappy
day and you don't feel like waving back,
they're smiling and looking at you and
going, "Hi, how are you? We had a
terrible day. See you later." you know,
um, the press, I've had I've done a
couple of interviews with the press over
the years where somebody will come up,
you're just hanging out by your car and
say, "Can I interview you for the local
TV station if you're not comfortable
with that, you know, find somebody else
who would do it, but uh, try it. It it's
fun actually to share your hobby with
other people." and um that it it's hard
sometimes to to get this all into
concise, you know, what's this deal
about? You know, well, it takes what,
three years to learn how to do it
anyway. But, you know, if you can
compress the story into like a 30 or 45
second soundbite, that really helps. Uh
but be polite with the press so they're
polite with us. the great race staff,
the people who are out in the
countryside doing the checkpoints. You
don't stop when you go by a checkpoint.
You don't talk to them. Um, you can
wave, you can smile. I usually like to
honk the horn a little bit and run your
headlight so they know that you're in
the race and that you're coming. They
don't have anything to do with the
scoring or how your day goes or if you
missed an intersection or this guy cut
you off or anything like that. That's
not their problem. If you have a problem
with the way the rally is being run, you
go to Brad. You don't talk to the staff.
The staff is volunteer primarily and we
want them to come back.
>> They're doing this on their vacations.
They're taking their vacation to support
Great Race every year. So,
>> these are awesome people. We love them.
>> Yeah. If if they aren't there, we don't
have a race. So, don't uh don't use
them.
>> Yeah. Don't express your outrage to any
of the great race staff except Brad.
He's used to it. He'll take care of it
for you.
>> Um, other racers,
there will be you, you guys are rookies.
Everybody has been a rookie. Everybody
knows that rookies make mistakes.
Experts make mistakes. Grand champions
make mistakes. Sometimes they're really
stupid mistakes. Um, but there are times
when the uh when people are not aware of
the fact that they have misadjusted
their speedometer and they're running
slower than everybody else and people
are coming up behind them and honking
their horn and thinking, "I'm right,
you're wrong and you're getting in their
way." Be aware that if you have like a
mechanical problem, you know, there's
another race car one minute behind you.
If you can get out of the of the lane
safely, get over to the side safely so
the next guy can come by and his time is
not messed up by your problem. Um the uh
the competition level, the grand
champions, they're in it for the money.
Uh and it's serious money. This one of
the things that makes Great Race
different from a lot of the other car
events that you go to. This is not
something that's done casually. It's
it's a pretty uh intense competition
especially for some folks um who are you
know really focused. We have a few
people who are not volunteering to help
with the rookies because their mindset
is that I'm focused on winning a lot.
Everybody else is out there to help you.
So, if you can't find your um
>> mentor,
>> your mentor and you have a question
during the race, you can come up to just
about anybody uh and say, "Excuse me, I
have a question. I'm a rookie and I'd
like to figure this out." 99% of the
time, they'll be happy to help you with
this because we were all rookies and
we've all been through this before.
>> And we want you to come back. We want
you to enjoy it and tell your friends
about it and keep this wonderful thing
that we are obsessed by um going year
after year. We've talked about the start
and restart positions where you're using
your order start to know where you're
supposed to be should you get lost and
everybody has gone off course before.
The idea being that you want to um
excuse me there um you would get back
just retrace your steps. How do you know
that you're off course? Is that a
separate course?
>> Yes, it is. We'll talk about that later.
>> So, we'll we'll talk about the fact that
if you get off course getting back into
the field, you want to be aware of where
your fellow competitors are so you're
not in their way while you're doing it.
Okay.
>> Okay. Um, one thing I do want to
impress, uh, regarding etiquette, the
way you drive,
um,
you have a big sticker on the side of
your car that says great race. You have
credentials around your neck that say
great race. You're probably wearing
shirts that say great race. If you're a
jerk,
that reflects badly on the great race.
So, if you're driving like a jerk, if
you're cutting people off, if you're
whipping in and out of traffic,
um Brad's going to get a call. So, don't
don't be that guy. Um you represent the
great race in everything you do for two
weeks. So, just keep that in mind.
>> Okay.
>> All right. Let's go through some course
instructions. But first, there are four
S's for success. Number one, which we
will um emphasize over and over and
over, safety first. Safety first. No
score is worth putting yourself, another
racer, or a spectator in danger. No
score is worth that. Drive safely at all
times. If an unsafe situation arises,
safety is more important than the race.
You can usually make up any lost time or
use a time allowance
um if it's an unsafe condition. So
safety first. Then the most important
thing after that start on time.
Everything in this race is is run on on
the clock to the second to the minute
and the seconds. Make sure that your
clock is calibrated every morning. You
may lose a half a second or a second a
day on your clock. You want to reset
that every day. That one second can be
critical.
Um so make sure you start on time. Use
your order of start make and compare
where you are in relation to the other
cars around you. Stay on course. So, you
may not necessarily be exactly at the
right speed all the time. Um, if you are
um looking for a turn and you're not
sure, um, you know, if it's a small side
road, you can see that your speed's
going to be 20 miles an hour. It's going
to be a small road. If your out speed is
45, you're looking for a pretty pretty
big road and it'll be pretty easy to
see. But, um, you might want to just
kind of slow down a little bit as you
approach what you think might be that
turn and then you can make up the extra
seconds for slowing down. It's better
than going blowing past and going, "Oh,
that was it." And then you've got to
whip around and you've lost 30 seconds
in turning around. So, um, stay on
course and that's going to save you
minutes.
>> Let me start just go back quickly to the
start on time. Um,
it may not be clear, but where the
official timing of the rally begins,
there's nobody there to tell you to go.
There's no race official. There's nobody
waving a flag. There is no checkpoint
crew. It's just that sign at the side of
the road.
>> It's you and the clock and your order of
start
>> and looking at the people that are
around you on your order of start. And
if you're not sure when you get up
there, you can look even if you park the
car, walk out, look to where the sign is
down the road and see the cars when
they're leaving and look at your order
of start and say, "Okay, they're 10
ahead of us. They're five ahead of us."
And if you get there late and you don't
recognize the cars that are in front,
you're already in trouble.
>> But that's another thing. Those cars
should be lined up behind that start
sign. You should be able to see, okay,
there's the Chevrolet truck, there's the
Alfa Romeo, there's the Ford Cabriolet,
there's the Rancherro, there's the
Chrysler, and then, okay, we're going to
tuck in behind this Mustang.
>> It's pretty obvious.
>> If you get there 10 or 15 minutes early,
do not pull up to that start sign. All
of those other cars deserve to be there
before you. So get find the car that
you're behind. Tuck in behind the car
that's in front of you. If he's the one
at the sign, don't be him.
>> Or you there are times when you'll just
you'll you'll motor past the sign and
say, "Oh, there's the start. Go down,
turn around, and come back and get in
line again." You can do that, too.
>> But don't get in the way of any cars
that are pulling away from that.
>> The guy's at the sign and he's got his
blinker on. Uh, let him go.
>> Okay. So, you're on course, stay on
time. If if you use your performance
chart, you follow the speeds, you're
going to have a good you're going to
have a good score. Um, for rookies, we
we figure if you stay within your
minute, if you stay behind the car in
front of you, stay in front of the car
behind you, you're going to have a good
day.
>> And since you're rookies, you're going
to be running in your own class. You're
going to be competing against other
rookies. Everybody's going to be at the
same skill level, basically. So, uh,
the, um, what am I saying? Uh, being in
your minute is what we teach. When you
get up to grand champion, then you're
looking at tenths of seconds. But that's
not you. You're looking to be in your
minute. Anytime you know, you got 30
seconds up and 30 seconds back. If you
can stay within like 15 seconds of that,
or if you're just you're not sure, you
drive up behind the car that's in front
of you, then back off a minute to put
yourself back in the position. You can
do stuff like that. You can use all the
information available to you to make
sure that you're about where you're
supposed to be.
>> Okay. So, let's go through root
instructions.
So, at the very beginning of the day,
the your root instructions are in three
sections. There's uh there's basically
five columns there. The first column 1 2
3 4 5 6 those are the your number uh
vertically vertically 1 2 3 4 5 6 those
are are your um your numerical
instructions. So instruction three is
the left turn instruction four is the
signal instruction five is the toll
booth and then across your column A is
going to be describing the road, the
signage, the intersections. what you're
going to be doing in column A. Column B
is whatever section section of the
course you are in. The first few
instructions you can see there are the
tire warm-up section. Then you can see
down at the bottom you will start a a
speedometer calibration. And I will go
through that step by step so you'll see
how that works. The next column is your
speed and timing. So it will tell you
what speeds you're going to be driving
at. um how many seconds or minutes
you're going to be holding those speeds.
And then the last column, that's kind of
a fun one. John likes to have fun with
that. Um it will give you some uh
special instructions. It might be
pointing out um look to your right.
You'll be able to see the blue whale off
in the distance. Um but but it might
just have um something like uh you can
see in instruction number three that
this is the fifth signal. So, um you'll
just be following that one by one and
then once you get to that fifth signal,
you'll see that that will show uh there
will be a sign to your left that will
say to I95 and you'll make that left
turn at that signal. So, that's that's
how these are laid out. Um at the very
bottom there are page numbers. So, it'll
say page one of 26. I will not leave the
scores table until I have flipped
through every one and I've seen two of
26, three of 26, four of 26. I want to
make sure before I leave, I have every
page uh accounted for.
>> Just so you know, the race is not
designed to try to trick you with the
course instructions. You may have gone
on other fun rallies with car clubs or
stuff like that where they try to make
some tricky thing that you have to
figure out to know where you're going.
This is not that. everything is as clear
as they can make it. You may not
recognize the instruction until you get
to it and say, "Oh, this is what they
mean by this. This primary road leads
off to the left." Um or uh so don't feel
like you have to secondguess the
instructions. They try very hard to make
sure that they are as clear and concise
as they can be.
So each instruction, you're just going
to follow it sequentially. The first
one, you're starting at a a playhouse.
You're turning right onto the street in
front of you. You are the dark arrow. So
the lighter colored lines are directions
that you don't take. So in this case,
you're pulling out onto the road. You're
turning right onto US number one, and
you're just turning right. You're going
to go um what is it? Nine miles. Um and
that's just to warm up your tires.
and continue on until you see
Shore Road Beach Street and you're going
to um go off to the left there. So, um
and once you've done that, then you
cross off that instruction, move to the
next one. You're looking for that fifth
signal turning left onto I 95,
uh or towards I 95. And uh the next
instruction, you're going to go under a
couple of overpasses. Add a signal.
You're going to turn right onto I95 and
it will tell you in that far right uh
column turn into the middle lane. Then
you'll your next instructor. So you're
going to mark that off. You've done
that. There's a toll booth. You're going
to stop at the toll booth. You're going
to pay your $150 and they will let you
know the day ahead whether there's any
upcoming tolls for the following day. So
you'll be prepared.
So then you'll continue. And what you're
looking for is um the next section you
can see the speedometer calibration sign
in the second column. You're going to
start that speedometer calibration at a
sign on the right. You see the arrow is
on the left. The sign is on the right.
So speed limit 65. That is where you
start your uh your stopwatch. Um your
driver is exactly at 50 m an hour and
you're just going to continue at 50 m an
hour until the next sign. So go on to
the next page.
The next sign will say again sign on
your right. Can bunk um port
>> can bunk can bunk port
>> whatever
>> there is an interval time and a
cumulative time that is shown. The
interval um I'm going to say okay our
next sign is coming up in four minutes.
We're looking for a sign on the right
cannab.
And um and then I'm going to hit pause
uh not pause um split on my um
on my stopwatch when I get to that that
point. And I'm going to write down the
time in in column D on my route
instructions. And then I'm not going to
do anything after I've written it down.
I'm going to hit split again. Now I'm
looking in another three minutes for a
sign on the left eastern trail
and when so 3 minutes past that canunk
sign it should be at that point elapse
time of 7 minutes 19.7 seconds that will
show on my split when I pass that sign.
I'm going to write that down. It's
probably I'm probably at 7 minutes 19.6
6 seconds, maybe 19.5 seconds.
I'm just going to write down what I
have. I'm not trying to match that. I'm
trying to compare what I have to what
the um optimal time is. So, you're going
to continue to do that at each one of
those signs.
>> Drivers, the helping your navigator,
like when you pass this sign on the side
of the road, you know what it looks like
when you have a a a sign on the side of
the road. When do you hit the stopwatch?
For us, what I do as a driver is I will
turn my head to the right and when the
two sticks that hold the sign together
are parallel, that's when I'll say mark.
And I'll do that each time. If the sign
is overhead, I'll use the bridge
abutment and use that the same way. So,
it depends on the team. the navigator
can do the stopwatch thing on their own,
but if the driver can help, that can
help. Especially if the sign is on the
left side of the road, and the driver
has a better view of it than the
navigator does.
>> Okay? So, you're going to do that for
every one of those signs. Just hit
split, split, split, split, split.
Write it down. Write it down. And what
you're looking for is a steady
progression of getting progressively
earlier or progressively later because
that tells you, okay, if it's a linear
progression of getting earlier or later,
you know, you're going to either make a
an adjustment to your speedometer or
you're going to be making an adjustment
manually during the day all day long
because
you want to um just compare to what that
perfect time is that they'll be using
for um your perfect arrival at those
checkpoints.
If sometimes there will be traffic and
you'll have to stop or slow down and you
won't be able to maintain that speed.
Okay? So, you you stop where you are.
You look for the next sign and you start
fresh again. That's why you've got those
elapse times between the two. So, you
can just add those together. Um instead
of looking for the cumulative, you make
your own new cumulative. So you can
start and and stop um if you need to.
>> The driver
>> sometimes I'll hit the stop button
instead of the the um split button.
That's when you do it again.
>> Yeah. The driver is looking ahead while
the navigator is making calculations as
to how early or late you are. If you see
that the traffic is stopped in front of
you in both lanes, you can tell the
navigator that we're going to have to
stop. And then when you get through that
traffic, you'll pull over, get to the
point where you can restart again, get
up to speed, and then the navigator will
tell you the next sign that you need to
have your speed up by. The one thing
that that gets us all the time as
drivers is if we're on like a threelane
road and you're in the right lane since
you're doing 50 and everybody else is
doing 80 or 92 or whatever. Um, if that
lane that you're in disappears
uh ahead,
the driver looks at that and says, "Oh,
dang. I'm going to lose this lane." It
gives you plenty of time to watch your
mirror and to merge into the left lane
while holding your speed. You make sure
that you don't have a truck that's doing
10 miles an hour faster than you are.
You don't want to wait for the last
minute to pull in front of him. If you
have to slow down to merge, you're going
to blow her time. Okay, let's go on to
the next slide. Then we're going to
continue. And there's the end of the
speedometer calibration. Um, sometimes
you'll see some of those overhead signs
will be directing you to be in certain
lanes so that you're ready to exit or to
merge onto a different um freeway. So,
um it'll tell you either stay there on
I95, so don't go to um the the other
option that you'll see there. um or
it'll tell you you're going to be moving
into, you know, I72, whatever it happens
to be. So, you follow those signs and
that will direct you to where you're
going to be. And then at the end, you
see the um
>> hourglass,
>> the hourglass there. And um that tells
you that you've come to the end of the
speedometer calibration and you're
starting a new section. So, this is an
offthe-clock
transit. Um and so um that tells you now
um that pain road half mile was the last
sign. Your total elapse time for that
speedometer calibration should have been
at 28 minutes 43.2 seconds. Whatever you
differentiate from that is your error
for a period of 28 seconds. If you
double that error that will let you know
how many seconds. Again, we're just uh
estimating here, but that will tell you
how many seconds early or late you are
in an hour.
And that's what you will use to reset
your speedometer. Um or um just know
that throughout the day, if you're say
you're 3 seconds early in the hour,
every 20 minutes all day long, you're
going to correct a second.
drivers. Um, you're waiting for your
navigator to tell you that you are off
the clock. That means you don't have to
hold that speed anymore. So, if you're
going off this freeway exit and it's at
a slower speed, you know that you don't
have to hold that speed anymore and
you're just driving on your own. Uh, the
driver needs to know when you're off the
clock and then you're just driving like
you would normally. Uh usually there's a
stop uh close by like you get off the
freeway and there'll be a gas station.
You'll have a chance to go to the
bathroom, top up the gas. Always make
sure that you top up the gas every
opportunity to get. The navigator is
figuring out the u
factor for the speedometer. And then you
can sit there, adjust the speedometer,
and then you're now ready to go when you
get to the official timed start. And in
this case, this is a um route
instructions from a uh practice rally.
And so it immediately took you into
lunch. We haven't even technically been
on the clock yet. So there's an
opportunity to h to have lunch. And you
see those numbers in parentheses. That
tells you how many minutes you are from
where the start will be. So you can see
uh where the cross uh knife and fork
are. It says 10 minutes right next to
that. That tells you you need to leave
there at least 10 minutes from that
intersection to be ready to go to your
start. And then when you in the next uh
intersection when you're turning left
onto uh Gorum at that signal, then
you're uh 6 minutes away from your
start. So now
next page
>> you might point out that this transit
zone is five miles and you have 55
minutes going into it. Oh, excellent.
Yes, thank you.
>> So that that lets you know how much time
you have to stop for gas
>> or to eat in this particular case
>> or use the bathroom
>> or all of the above
>> or all of them.
>> Okay. So now you see these Santaas in
the bottom of the hourglass after a
couple more turns and there is a time of
day clock. That is your start. So, you
are actually starting the competition
for the first time a couple hours after
you left the hotel and you are starting
at a stop ahead sign.
Okay,
>> that's terrible
>> but it happens. So, it is telling you
okay at
140 plus your start position. So if I
was start position from my um start
order of start position 30, I am going
to leave there at 210.
So 140 + 30 and I'm going to leave that
stop ahead sign at 20 m an hour. But I'm
not going to leave right at 210. I'm
going to leave at 209
less about a second and a half because
that's how much we lose accelerating up
to 20.
And then obviously there's going to be a
stop sign that's going to come real soon
after that and then you'll be ready to
make that right turn at that stop.
Generally
at a stop sign they will allow you a
15-second pause. That 15 seconds allows
you to compensate for the time that you
lost in decelerating to the stop and
accelerating up to what is that 25 35
mph. So you're coming in at 20, you're
probably losing a couple seconds
decelerating down to zero and then
you're losing a couple more seconds
accelerating up to 35. So say that total
is 5 seconds loss. You're only going to
pause for 10 seconds.
So that will get you right on time when
you leave
and you that's all based on what you see
on your performance chart based on how
you drive the car and based on how your
car performs. So you'll subtract your
acceleration loss and your deceleration
loss from that 15 seconds. That's how
long you pause. And then you continue at
35 miles an hour.
Um, so you're at 35 miles an hour until
you see a speed limit 35 sign on your
right. You will go down to 30 m an hour
and you will stay at 30 m an hour until
you see that next sign, which is a stop
sign.
And again, you'll go down to zero. There
is a 15-second pause allowed. And then
you'll go up to 30.
Um, now the next one is a blinky light.
It does not say stop. However, there is
a 15-second pause in the instructions.
So, you will treat that as if it were a
stop. I'm going to write stop and big
letters, and I'm going to highlight it
in yellow. So, again, you'll treat it
exactly the same as you would have uh if
it were a regular stop sign.
Okay? And when Steve gets back, I will
ask him to tell you about splitting
signs. Let's go on to the next slide.
Uh, okay. What instructions are? Okay.
Um, on the previous page, you were 30 m
35 miles an hour.
What you want to do is
you don't the remember drivers are
stupid. They they don't remember what
speed you told them to go to. So, I will
always write down the speed from the
bottom of the previous page at the top
of the next page to remind me we are
still at 35. We're going to continue 35
until we get to this street where we're
going to be turning right and going out
at 30 m an hour.
Okay. Um, in the next instruction, you
see a small sign in the instruction.
When you see a sign before uh an
intersection like that and there is a
speed change, you can see that we're at
30, we're going down to 20. You're not
going to turn uh you're not going to go
down to 20 at the turn. You're going to
go down to 20 at the sign if it's
showing a picture of a sign in the route
instructions.
Okay? So, you're down to 20. And then,
um you're going to make that right turn
onto that street at 20 miles an hour.
Okay. Um, next one. There's a just again
a couple more stops. Same same process.
Um, you you pause for whatever um you
need to based on your performance chart.
Um uh and then you can see that after a
couple more stops there is a right turn
on Hearn Road that does not have a stop.
And so you're going into the turn at 40
miles an hour. You're coming out of the
turn at 35 miles an hour. That is when
you're going to use your performance
chart because you know that you will uh
be going down to 15 miles an hour at
that turn and then accelerating back up
to 35. And so that's what you're going
to be referring to your chart and making
up the time lost from that turn.
Okay. Um continue. We've got a couple
more um stops and turns. Going on to the
next slide.
See, it's pretty easy. It's just one
after another after another. Soon as
you've done it, cross it off. Mark down
your your speed uh at the top of the
next page. Okay, you're going 30. You
get to a speed limit 25 sign and you're
going to be going down to 20. So Steve,
if you'll tell them what the process for
splitting a sign is.
>> Drivers, there's a technique for
splitting a sign. That is that you're
not waiting until you're a beam the sign
before you make your speed change. What
you're going to do is start the speed
change before you get there. The idea is
that you want to hit that sign right
about the middle of your speed change.
So if you're doing 30 and it's going
down to 20, you want to go to 25 a beam
the sign. So then you're at 20 on the
other side of it. That way there's no
calculations that need to be made either
going faster or slower because you split
the sign. you've averaged out both sides
of it and you're right on time.
>> And that works both going up and going
down.
Okay. So, um there is nothing at the
next sign. You can sometimes you'll just
see a blank box in the middle of your
route instructions. That means there is
a a left jog sign there, but you're not
going to change speed at it. But I will
always write in whatever the previous
speed was just so that I know yes, uh
there was not a speed change there. We
continue at 20 until the next
instruction. But what this is telling
you, this is warning you there's a comes
quick there on the right. And so that's
saying when you see that left jog sign,
there's a real hard right turn on Ricker
coming up right after that. So look
sharp. So you use all the instructions
um that are there to give you those
clues so that you don't miss a turn and
get lost.
>> Drivers, again, there will be acute
angles. That's right. Not obtuse, right?
That's an acute angle.
>> That is an acute angle. Very good.
>> Um, where you can't see where the road
there might be trees or stuff there's or
you can't actually see the road going
off to the right. Sometimes I'll use
like power lines. Power lines go down
along roads. If there's a power line
that looks like it's crossing somewhere
in the middle, I might use that as a
clue is that the road is going to be
there. Um, sometimes traffic coming the
other way will be making their left turn
on that road, so you'll know right where
it is. Uh, but if you don't have any
visual clues where it's at, you know,
you're only doing 25,
if you have to slow down so you make the
turn, most of us can make it at 20 or,
you know, somewhere over 15, you might
be making a pretty quick maneuver there.
But this is going to be driver. Look for
Yeah. Sometimes driveways will fool you.
You'll come up to something and you'll
see a driveway and you'll want to turn
into the driveway and go, "Oh crap,
that's a driveway." Um, and that doesn't
look sharp, how do you think? But that
comes with experience. You just keep
doing it and and practice it. Uh if you
go past it, what you want to do is you
want to turn around when it's safe
because if there's traffic behind you or
traffic coming, you don't want to make a
Uturn in the middle of the road and have
somebody hit you. The navigator hits the
stopwatch. As soon as you start going
back to that intersection, that's half
the time that you've lost. You double
that. You know how long it you're off
course when you did that. It's really
simple.
>> Okay, so we're following instructions
one by one. We pass a speed limit sign,
change uh make a hard ride at a stop
sign. And then I want you to notice he
has written down comes quick because
when we go to the next slide, you'll see
at the top of the next page, there's a
comes quick of a of a um right curve
sign where you're going to you're
the
>> delayed.
>> It's a delayed speed change. You don't
do anything.
um you hit your stopwatch or you write
down that your time of day and then 1
minute and 39 seconds later
you will increase speed up to 30 minute
30 miles hour. So um and that's that's
common. It it might be that um the speed
that you're at is sufficient to take you
through that curve. And then once you
pass that curve, then he's increasing
you up to 30 m an hour uh to meet the
the needs of the road at that time.
Okay. So, continuing on a couple more
stops. We've got again a sign before a
turn. So, you'll decrease down to 30
miles an hour at that uh right uh side
road sign. You turn right onto Lowden
Road. Uh, and you can see that there's a
minus 2.3 that he's written there. That
that is something that he's written in
from his performance chart that says
when he makes that right turn from 35 to
30 m an hour, he's lost 2.3 seconds. And
so, he's going to make up 2.3 seconds on
the other side. We'll tell you how to do
that in a couple minutes. Again, you've
got another sign, another speed change,
another stop. Um, and you've got a clue
here in the right that um, you won't see
this river road intersection until after
that sign that's kind of at an angle.
So, look for that sign. Then look for
that road. Make that turn. And it looks
like we've got another comes quick after
that. So, next slide. Another comes
quick. We've got um, so no speed change,
but again, a look sharp turn after that.
So, use all of the information,
especially in column D. That's going to
help you with a lot of things that uh
that you would be uh confused about, but
also to set you up to find those signs,
to find those terms ahead of time.
All right. Um, look sharp. John is
really good about this is a first paved
road, so there might have been a bunch
of dirt roads, gravel roads, uh,
driveways. Um, but once once you see
this, it'll be the first paved road that
you'll be turning on. He's very specific
about that. He's not going to take you
down a gravel road unless it says short
gravel road. Use caution or something.
And he'll have you at a low enough speed
so that you're not going to be kicking
up a bunch of um rocks on your car.
However, we will be driving on old Route
66 a lot. A lot of old Route 66 is in
really bad shape. If you have a really
nice paint job, um, enjoy it before the
race.
>> Fair warning.
>> Um, yeah, we we ended up with a crack in
a windshield from Old Route 66 last
time.
>> Hey, hey, clear bra is your friend. You
can put it in the front. It's great
stuff. Great stuff.
>> Yes, you're right.
>> Okay. Um, again, more more turns, more
signs, one after another. Do the
instruction, mark it off. Some people
scratch through the whole thing. I just
do a little tick mark on the side just
cuz I want to go back and and review
them again later. Let's see where I
screwed up. Um, look sharp. All of those
are very helpful. Not intended to
confuse you at all. Okay, next slide.
Um, okay. We're getting into a transit.
Transits are fun. Again, more more of
the same instructions. Um,
comes very quick. All right. the the
transit is at the stop ahead sign. That
is uh the next instruction down. You've
got the the uh hourglass and it's
telling you that you're going to be
going 10 miles and it's going to take
you 30 minutes to do that. The reason
for that is that you can see a little
rustic bathroom down there. This is a
bathroom stop. You might see rather than
the bathroom picture, you might see a
gas pump. So, if it's a bathroom stop,
they'll usually give you 15 minutes plus
the um time that it would take you to
traverse the uh the road that you're on.
The important thing is when you cross
that stop ahead sign, write down the
exact time of day. The exact time of
day, hours, minutes, seconds. Then you
will add that 30 minutes that he's
allotting you and you will carry that
forward onto the instruction that will
be on the next page that will tell you
when to restart. So it's really
important that you write down that exact
time, add the 30 minutes or whatever the
time is that he's allotted you transfer
that onto that next page. So let's go
ahead. So he's going to take you to a
place where there's bathrooms. We're
going to go around a traffic circle and
there is Hey Janet, can I make one note?
>> Yes, you may.
>> From a from a the experience of doing
this, there is sometimes a tendency to
say, "Oh, 30 minutes. I'll just hit my
stopwatch and when it finishes 30
minutes, I don't have to worry about any
of this."
>> And you're late.
>> We have seen so many people that go,
"Whoops." And then they hit the button
on the stopwatch and they don't know
what where they are. So, it is much
better to actually write the time down
and
>> do that. Do both. I'm looking for that
sign. I'm looking at my clock. I'm
writing down the hour. I'm writing down
the minute. I'm looking for the second
on my clock to come around. I've got
this the stopwatch at zero. I'm looking
at the clock. 56, 57, 58, 59. There's
the sign. Hit the stopwatch. And then I
write down the 59. So, um, you're kind
of doing a lot of things at once as a
navigator, but it's real important to
have that backup on your stopwatch and
then look at it a minute later to make
sure that your second was right, because
sometimes your second might be off by a
second or two. All right, so now you're
out in the middle of nowhere. You've
just gone to the bathroom. There's a
speed limit 25 with about four cars
behind it. They should be the four cars
that are directly in front of you on
your uh order of start so you know
you're in the right place at the right
time. This is also a good opportunity to
watch what second everybody else leaves
because then you'll know whether you're
doing really good or like, "Oh, they
left 30 seconds before we're supposed to
leave. We must have screwed up." No,
they did.
>> So, could be could be you don't know.
You just you're just verifying,
>> but it's just it's using the information
available. If it's somebody that has
grand champion next to their name,
chances are pretty good.
>> If you leave it the right second, but
don't change your second because there
might have been a checkpoint in between,
>> right?
>> So, um, you just use all the information
available to you. Again, another series
of Oh, this is a maze. These are fun.
Okay, mazes are when there's just a
whole sequence of turns, usually at slow
speeds. Sometimes there's stops,
sometimes there's not. So be careful and
um just follow them again. Mark it off
one after another after another after
another. Stay at the speed whatever was
given to you. Let's go on to the next
slide.
Oh, and there's a couple more. And
there's a couple with stops. Follow
those instructions. Now, here's
something new. There's a camera, a
picture of an old video camera with a
slash through it. What that tells you is
at that point there could be something a
little tricky on the course that um they
don't want to subject you to having to
run into a checkpoint. So, it's
protecting you. Um so, you may get off
um you may get off speed and you may
need to have time to fix it. Um but at
least between those instructions with
the slash through it and when the camera
is down there again at the at the bottom
that you won't see a checkpoint there.
It's probably because of that signal,
that signal with the arrow pointing to
it.
It's infrequent, but there will be times
that you will be on a clock going
through a signal. Of course, you won't
know whether it's going to be green or
red when you get there. So, you're going
to have to be prepared to either do the
stop at the signal
or go through the signal and do the stop
on the other side of the intersection.
So, um, they're just allowing you to to
make up for whatever error you may
encounter there. You'll make a right
turn. You'll probably be, let's see, on
that road, you'll be at 40 miles an hour
for a while before you make that turn um
onto uh Sam Allen. So, you'll have time
to make up whatever uh error you might
have encountered at that signal. And
then you'll be back where there could be
a checkpoint at any time.
Um, again, down at the bottom there's a
blinky instead of a um a stop sign, but
treat it as a stop stop sign.
All right, next slide.
Oh, my favorite. Off the clock. When you
see the um digital clock with the slash
through it, you are off. It's the end of
the time section. It's the um this is
the end of the day. Uh, and it's telling
you you now have 30 minutes to go 9
miles or whatever it is. John wants you
to stop for gas. That gives them time to
create your uh scorecard. And so when
there's a a picture of a gas pump, you
will stop for gas whether you need it or
not. Um, it's also a good time to get
something to drink uh because you've got
for transit to get into the finish.
Janet, don't you recommend uh every time
there's a checkpoint and in this case at
the end as a backup to record time of
day?
>> Oh, absolutely. Yes. Thank you for for
that. Um again, those checkpoints will
be randomly anywhere. When you see a
checkpoint, I will always write it in
column D in a nice big empty space. I'll
make a little check mark. I'll I'll put
a one next to it or two three four so I
know the number of what checkpoint it
was an exact time of day. If there's any
discrepancy between you and the scoring
team, if you don't know what time you
passed that checkpoint, they're not
going to be able to fix it and make any
corrections. You know, you say, "Well,
I've got a 30 second uh leg here. I know
I was on time." Well, prove it. Tell me
what time you crossed the checkpoint.
You've got to have that information. So,
write that down.
Okay. Now, when you get to the end of
your route instructions, there will be a
couple of information boxes. The first
one will be uh what is going on that
evening. It'll tell you if there's a
host dinner. It'll tell you how long you
need to stay at the park for May. It'll
tell you about parking information at
the hotels. So, it's really important to
read all of that information.
Um there will also be a box which I'll
show you uh on one of the next slides
about um submitting a time allowance.
that will also be uh towards the end of
the instructions here. Okay. So, next
slide there will be an information
>> there's a note for observation
checkpoint here too just to mention.
>> Ah
okay.
Um
>> the red yes when you pull in at the very
end at the hotel or the the um the
finish gate there will be a red sign
that says great race. that's down at at
the uh at on the ground level and you
must stop there and um talk to the staff
that are there and that's usually when
they'll give you your your score sheet
and other information and your uh start
order for the next day.
Okay. Information box two on the next
page tells you what will happen the next
day. So, it'll tell you what the start
time is, whether there's any uh tolls,
um where you're going to pick up your
course instructions because it isn't
necessarily at the hotel you are staying
at. So, you're going to need to know how
to get to the hotel where you're picking
up your route instructions the following
day. So, that's really important that
you add that into your preparation for
starting the day.
Okay. So let's look at the
climb allowance
instructions.
So um sometimes you will lose time
during due to circumstances beyond your
control, slowmoving vehicles in front of
you. There will be farm vehicles. There
will be school buses. Yay. We have lots
of stories about school buses. Buy us a
drink. We'll tell you. um construction
area, traffic, cross traffic, small
towns, um cross traffic at
intersections. Um you could be caught by
a train. You probably will be caught by
a train at some point. And they um would
like you to make up whatever time you
lose to the best of your ability. Don't
just assume, oh, I lost 30 seconds
there. I'm just going to turn in a time
allowance and they will um approve it
and I won't have to do any work. 30
seconds is pretty easy to make up. So,
um you want to try to um
limit your your time allowances um to
even them into 10 second increments
because you can turn in a time allowance
for 10-second increments, but make up
whatever time you can safely. If you
can't make it up safely, if there's
another rally car in front of you, you
cannot get around it to increase your
speed. You stay where you are and you
submit your time delay and you just say,
"I couldn't make it up safely." Um, and
but also don't cheat. You can't submit a
time allowance if you missed a turn or
if you had a mechanical difficulty. Um,
so this is the process for the time
allowance. What you'll see on your route
instruction is a box that says um within
15 minutes you go to
greatcores.com/timeallowance
and you will submit your time
allowances. This is an app on your
phone. You'll see your car number. They
give you a fourdigit password and you'll
put in your password. You'll put in the
phone number that you're using for the
cell phone that you're using for uh time
allowances.
And then you'll enter whatever your time
allowance is. In this particular
instance, um, on leg three between
instructions 44 and 45, we were stopped
for 3 minutes and 40 seconds by a train.
Submit.
All right. So, maybe I had another one
later in the day. Maybe I had maybe I
had three or four of them and it was
really bad day. And you just continue to
submit them. And then at the very end of
the day when allowances have been
submitted, you click that red box and
you are done. that tells them I am done.
You may now print my scorecard.
And you will be doing that twice a day.
The red button is only at the end of the
day, but you will you'll submit that uh
at lunch and then at the end of the day.
Okay. So,
special situations
um making up time. Again, anytime you
make a turn, um you're going to be uh
you're you will have lost time. You will
need to make it up. Um the best way to
do that, the easiest way to do that is
what we call the 10% rule. If you are
going 30 miles an hour and you have lost
5 seconds,
I have my driver go 10% faster to 33
miles an hour
for 10 times the number of seconds we're
we're so 5 seconds late, then we're
going to go 50 seconds at 10% over at 33
miles an hour. That will put us right
back on time.
Okay. Um, so 30 to 33, 40 to 44, 50 to
55,
48 to 52.8,
but and you can also do this in reverse
if you need to lose time. Sometimes you
may need to leave a stop early if
there's cross traffic coming and so it's
like, oh, we're 5 seconds early. Okay.
So, drop down 10%, drop down to 27 for
50 seconds, and then you're right back
on time.
>> Drivers, this one's for you. If you're
looking in your rearview mirror and you
see five gravel trucks coming,
leave. Tell them, tell your navigator,
"We're going to leave now." Hit She'll
hit the stopwatch. You're leaving early.
That's okay. You put those seconds in
your pocket. If you're coming up to a
stop sign as your next instruction, you
just bleed them off there. So, it's okay
to leave early as long as you know how
early you are. And believe me, it's the
better part of discretion for the driver
to say, "Oh crap, I got to get out of
here." And and go, you can bleed off
those extra seconds later.
>> Okay, so that's the 10% rule for making
up time. Now, finally, special situation
when you're lost. Next slide. Sometimes
you just blow it. You miss a turn. You
miss an instruction. If you're driving
at a speed that does not correspond with
the road you're on, you may be wrong.
If you encounter a stop sign and there
is not a stop sign on your course
instruction, you are wrong.
If you're on a long straight road, say
you're driving 30 miles an hour, long
straight road, and you can't see the car
in front of you or behind you, you may
be wrong.
So, go ahead.
>> There are times, drivers, when you're
going along, you don't see anything,
you're not sure, you haven't had an
instruction for the last 10 minutes. Uh,
you don't know if you're on the right
course or not. If you're if you're not
sure, the easiest thing to do as a
rookie is to just pull over and stop. If
you're on the course, there's going to
be a car right behind you one minute. If
the car comes by, you go, "Oh crap, we
were on the right course." is you're
gonna get up there, pass that car, get a
minute in front of him, whatever that
is, and you've pretty much fixed it. Um,
the trick is not to go well, we have
fooled ourselves sometimes and saying,
"We must have missed a turn. This is too
long. This is too long. Oh, wait,
there's the sign." Uh, that will happen.
Don't second guess it. Uh, there are
other things that you can use. For
example, if the speed limit says 30 and
they've got you at 50, you know you're
wrong. Um the uh those things can make a
big difference. You hit a stop sign and
you're supposed to be making a right
turn next, you know you're wrong. Turn
around. Start your stopwatch.
Go back to where you knew you were on
course. Look to see race cars coming by.
Use your order. Start. Say, "Okay, these
guys were 10 behind us." Get in like at
the 32nd spot. If you got cars one
minute apart, try to insert yourself in
the 32nd spot so you don't mess up
either one of those cars and you'll know
how far back you are. Now, if you don't
have time to pass all those cars to get
back to your slot, this leg is blown.
You know, you're back on course. You're
you're running again, but don't try to
do anything heroic like I have done in
the past and and try to get yourself
back into position. Um, you're going to
have throwaway legs. Your worst scores
are going to be discarded. So, you just
look at this and say, "Okay, that's my
discarded leg." But now you're in the
racecourse
back further than you were. So when you
cross a checkpoint, okay, that previous
leg is blown. But when you cross that
checkpoint, you're on a brand new one
where you've got a zero error going into
it. Follow all the instructions that
you're supposed to follow. Even if
you're 30 seconds behind the car in
front of you, or if he's a good if he's
a good racer, you want to stay that 30
seconds behind. But you're now going to
be driving it the rest of the uh time
either up to lunch or to the end of the
race in that slot. That's where you are
now.
>> Yeah. And and be careful. That's a
really big thing. If you're if you're
moving fast and you're trying to get
around somebody or trying to get in
position and you come through a
checkpoint, try not to be right on the
bumper of the car ahead of you because
as you pass through and you're both
zeroed again, you're going to stick
right there for that entire leg and it's
aggravating for everybody. So, give
everybody a little breathing room and
make it up with your stopwatch. So, a
good thing to do if you find yourself on
the bumper of another car crossing a
checkpoint, drop back 30 seconds. Submit
a time delay that you were right next to
another race car and you drop back 30
seconds for safety.
That'll give you a little bit of
breathing room so you're not in each
other's way at stop signs.
>> There's way to ways to fix just about
everything.
Okay, we're getting to the top of the
hour and there's just uh like a one uh
one more slide. Yeah, we'll open this up
for any questions, but I wanted to just
uh I found this quote and I loved it. Um
winning is fun. Sure, winning is not the
point. Wanting to win is the point. Not
giving up is the point. Never letting up
is the point. Never being satisfied with
what you've done is the point. This is
Pat Summit, who is one of the greatest
women's basketball coaches, uh,
University of Virginia. Um, to finish is
to win. So, do the best you can. We're
in we're in your corner. We're here to
help you. We're here to answer any
questions. We'll stay on the line for as
long as anybody has questions. If you
want to unmute yourself, feel free. Um,
I see some great conversations that
happened in the uh in the chat box.
Looks like a lot of those questions were
answered, but feel free just uh jump out
and ask any questions you have.
>> So, one of the people, some of them were
asking when they get their car number.
>> Is that posted? Is the list of entrance
posted on the website now, Brad?
>> I answered that a few times, I think,
but it kept kind of coming up in the
long chat. If you're a great racer and
you're going to spring rally, you will
get your great race numbers and stickers
at spring rally at registration. if
you're not.
>> But some people don't know actually what
their race car number is.
>> I know what the race car number is.
>> They'll get that a few weeks before the
race and it'll be
>> and but the the mentors have all been
given the car numbers for their um
rookie. So when I sent the emails out, I
said your rookie is car number 47 and
they're driving a 62 tornado, whatever
it is. So um your your mentor will know
your car number as well.
>> Great. But your physical
mailed to you.
>> Yeah. But, you know, if you want to get
cool uh, you know, hats and shirts with
your number embroidered on them, you
want to have time to do that because
it's neat.
>> There you go. There you go.
>> Okay. Any other questions? Feel free
again, unmute yourself and and shout it
out.
>> I have I have a question. Can you hear
me?
>> Sure.
>> So, two questions real quick. Do you
when you do the speed change, come to a
sign, travel at 20 miles an hour for 40
seconds, and then go to 35, do you split
that as well? How do you how do you do
the speed change there? What's a
practical way to do that?
>> If if you're doing a speed change at a
sign,
>> no. Well, so you come to a sign at 20
miles an hour and then it says 1 minute
30 seconds,
>> 35 miles an hour.
>> Got it.
I I usually shave off a couple seconds.
>> Okay. All right. So, so in other words,
if if we're if if it says to hold 20 for
a minute and 12 seconds and then go to
35, I will usually um back up about 2
seconds beforehand and say, "Okay, go to
35 now." And it'll be maybe at at 1
minute 10 instead of 1 minute 12. So
that way you're kind of um uh splitting
the sign virtually. So, what she'll do
is as the driver, she's going to tell
me, you know, go to the next speed now,
which is fine. She'll compensate for the
reaction time that it takes to move the
pedal or 3, two, one, and then I'll hit
it at one.
>> Okay. The same along the same lines,
when you do a stop, what's a practical
way to how do you count down? Do you do
3, two, one, go, or 3, two, one, and
then the driver knows to proceed? Um I I
will do a full countdown. So if I know
that we have a pause of um you know I'll
say okay we're we're um coming in at 20
out speed 35 um holding for nine and you
know rock back 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 go 30.
And so he knows when the go is and what
the speed is. And as a driver,
>> what I'm doing is looking for cross
traffic as she's counting down. So, I'm
calculating in my mind, am I going to
have time to go before this car gets
there, or am I going to have to wait
until that car goes by? And I'll tell
her, keep counting. So, she'll go 3 2 1
0 1 2 and I go.
>> And you have the stopwatch going at the
same time, right? So, you know how long
you were stopped. It it depends on what
your technique is. There there are, you
know, experts and grand champions will
have different techniques for timing
stops than rookies do. I I encourage you
just use your performance chart and your
time of day clock and just put your
finger on your clock and, you know,
count down 9 876 on your time of day
clock.
>> Sometimes you can't leave right away.
Sometimes it takes a while before you
get a chance to leave that stop sign.
and you may have that finger on that
clock and and be writing something down
in your route instructions at the same
time.
>> Or I know I've got 90 seconds and I see
seven gravel trucks coming. I'll leave
early and let her know that we're
leaving early so we're not waiting there
longer. That these are driver decisions
that you make for the circumstances.
>> Great. Thank you,
>> Janet. Sure,
>> Derek. When you guys do the tire
warm-up, speedometer check, um
>> I I I don't and I think you probably
don't either. You don't give feedback to
the driver because you don't want him to
adjust his driving.
>> Oh, we're running early. We're running
early. Go faster.
>> No. As a driver, my best uh deal of the
day is I'm holding that speed exactly
where it's supposed to be for the entire
amount of time she tells me to do it.
That's my job and I'm going to do that
regardless.
>> And then I will just do the math
afterwards to figure out, okay, I'm
either going to um change the
speedometer or I'm going to be making
corrections throughout the course of the
day.
>> Um
>> your question just came up in the chat.
How can you tell if you're running early
or late? You guys, this is a good one.
>> Seat of the pants guessing.
>> Actually, I guess that might be in
respect to speedometer check, but
realistically on the course, you won't
know.
>> We have no idea. You have no idea.
>> You'll come through the day and think
you nailed everything. You know, you you
are perfect.
>> I think we got a one early on that one.
It's like, okay, that was our second
ace.
And then you come in and you got an 18
second score and it's like what?
>> Or vice versa, you know, you think,
"God, that was rough. We did all these
corrections, all these time
corrections."
>> And they hand you an a sticker
>> and you just laugh at the at the finish
line. It's like, "What the hell? I'll
take it." But, you know, so you don't
really know. That's that's part of the
deal. The the only thing that could give
you an idea is if there's a restart
after a transit and there's a couple of
of um expert or grand champions uh in
front of you and you see what time they
leave and you see what time you're
leaving. It's like, oh, we're running
late or we're really early. What
happened?
>> And there have been times when we've
adjusted our time based on what those
guys did. You know, if we really trust
that team and we look at each other and
say, "What do you think?" And say,
"Let's
>> don't do that. Don't do that.
>> Let's fix it.
>> Run your own race."
>> Yeah. You don't know what you did wrong
if you try that. You know, once you get
your score back and you look through
your sheets and you can see uh clue by
clue as you go down, you can kind of
figure out where you had your problem.
You want to learn from that. Um, so
yeah, as she said, it's better to do
that, but we've done it the other way,
too.
>> If if you're a rookie, and I'm going
back many years, long before I had
mentors like Stephen Janet here, I ran
with stock speedos. I ran with a
timewise that I had no idea how to set.
There was there's a lot of things that I
did wrong as I was learning, but you
learn the kind of hacks to get through
this as you're figuring it out. and
you're going to learn how to you may not
on your first day figure out how to be
perfectly timed and understand how to
read all these signs. Don't panic. It's
not that big of a deal. Your main thing
on your timing as a brand new person
doing this, if you're consistently
trying to run over the car that's
supposed to be ahead of you by a minute,
you're probably running fast. Back it
up. And if you're on the, you know, the
other side of it, if someone is running
you over or you're always kind of seeing
somebody in your mirror, well, you're
probably running slow. So, you can get
little checks on yourself throughout the
day. If you're on a long stretch and you
see the glint of the silver car ahead of
you in the distance, if you're not using
your SP using your stopwatch, get a
little mark on them and you'll see a big
hickory tree at the beginning of a of a
bridge. And you can give yourself a
little a little hack along the way. It's
not official. It's not exact, but it can
give you a little bit of a hint that
okay, maybe we should be running 42
instead of 45 until we figure out how to
really get this speedometer set up. And
you experiment a little bit.
>> Just some little tips and tricks out
there. Again,
>> there are a lot of people that again, if
you just don't get lost, that's where it
gets really complicated. Stay on course,
learn your instructions, try not to run
over somebody or get run over from
behind and learn. You're you're going to
have a great time. Don't panic.
>> That's what we say to stay within your
minute. That's what we try to teach the
rookies. You've got 30 seconds on either
side to play with. If you can finish
each leg within your minute, you're
doing great.
>> You're doing You're doing phenomenally
well. I am I am famous for um passing
the same checkpoint five times on on on
one race.
early on. So, just smile, enjoy
yourself. It's, you know, this is great
and everyone will help you whether
they're an expert or not. When the time
is right and they sit down and you just
put your instructions in, you go, "What
on earth?" They're going to be like,
"Give me that thing." Everyone, this is
a family. Everyone's here to make
friends. Everyone's here to have a good
time. So, there's a lot of information
here. It's fantastic. Fantastic
information. It's very advanced and this
is what it takes to win, but you can
have a really great time as you learn
and as you get up to this. Um,
>> our primary concern with what we're
doing right now is to give people who
have never done it an idea of what
they're coming up to. You're not going
to remember everything we said here.
You're not going to remember everything
that's being said on the next rally
school, but there will be a next rally
school when you guys get to your start.
There will be a rally school. We'll be
doing it. Director of competition will
be doing it. We'll be going over this
material again. We'll be working with
you. The the best way to learn is if you
make a mistake and you come to us and
say or anybody really what happens when
this occurs. When you figure out how to
fix something that'll stick
throwing stuff against the wall right
now. We're just trying to give you an
overview. We'll be covering it again.
We'll be there to answer your questions.
Uh there's nothing like being out there
and say, "Okay, it's time to go." And
get out there and give it a try. Uh but
it's depending on you guys are rookies.
Stay in your minute. Stay on course.
You'll do fine. It'll be great.
>> Uh if I can jump in real quick. I've
I've got to get offline here in just a
minute. I'm Ray. Like
>> hello. Hi. rookie extraordinaire here.
Okay. A lot of the things you were
talking about uh just went okay because
I got to learn.
>> You mentioned a mentor.
>> Yeah.
>> Um how when will we find out who our
mentor is?
>> You should have received an email. I
sent emails to every rookie driver and
navigator that was on my spreadsheet. I
assigned you a mentor either based on
geographical area um or time zone. So
you should have received an email
probably three weeks ago and your mentor
should have also received it with your
contact information.
>> Okay. Nobody has reached out to me. I'll
go back and I'll look Janet and then um
>> I've got so many questions I don't want
to take up everybody's time. So would I
reach out to my mentor or can I speak to
>> You can email us directly. That's not a
problem.
>> Okay. Uh, and I don't know if I got that
email, Janet. Can you give me your email
address now or?
>> Yes, absolutely. It's j
>> j h
d keyahoo.com.
>> That's easy.
>> And it may have gone into your your
spam. So, you know, look for your spam
because it should say um your veteran
mentors for the 2026 great race and it
would have their name and their contact
information.
>> All right, then I'll I will let you guys
I don't want to take up any more
anybody's time. I'll look for that and
then if I got it, I'll look at it, but
I'll probably reach out to you by
tomorrow.
>> And it wasn't from a great race email
address. It's from her.
>> No, it was from me. It was from me.
>> Okay. So, it may have gone to my spam
and if it did, I may have passed by it
not not realizing. So, possible and and
you're it the same thing could have
happened with your mentors because I
would have sent them an email that said
your great race rookies to mentor and
here is here's their name. So I will
look for both of those emails and I will
contact you.
>> Thanks. Thank you very much guys. I got
to run.
>> Don't worry. We'll take care of you.
>> I'll I'll I'll talk to you all soon. And
thank you so much. Fantastic
presentation. Thank Thank you very much.
>> And we we still got 70 people on the
call. So again, as long as as long as
you ask questions, we're here.
>> That your questions may be the same that
some other folks have. You got one
that's really burning on you right now.
>> Yeah, you're on mute,
>> Ray. You're on mute.
>> Oh, Ray, hang on.
>> Sorry about that. I didn't realize it
was back on mute. Um I've got so many
and I don't want to tear up everybody's
time and I'm a single dad, so I've got a
little girl to get into bed. So got take
care of her first.
>> Thanks, guys. Appreciate y'all. Take
care. We'll be in touch.
>> The question came up again on chat. When
will you get your car numbers? If you're
going to the spring rally, you'll get
them there. And otherwise, it sounds
like this year they're at registration
and not being mailed. Correct.
>> We are. No, we are. We are mailing them.
You will pick them up at spring rally if
you're also doing Great Race. If you're
just doing Great Race, they'll be mailed
after spring rally. So, the first couple
of weeks of May, you should receive
them.
>> Perfect. But I think I think that
there's a distinction between are they
asking about their stickers that go on
their car that have their car number on
it or are they just asking what is my
car number going to be? So I know that
I'm car number one was just about the
decals the car number decals and sponsor
details.
>> Okay. Yeah. If if you just want to know
what your car number is going to be so
that you can go ahead and have it
embroidered on shirts and hats and
stuff. I have a master list that has
that. When I sent out the emails to the
mentors, it gave your car number um to
your mentors. So, um if you just want to
know, oh yeah, I'm car number 137,
Marilyn. Uh
then, um your your mentor can tell you
or I can.
>> Janet, um what was your email address
that you sent out? Um I'm I'm still
looking through my emails to try to find
it.
>> Just put it in.
should put it in the chat.
>> Okay, I'll look in chat.
>> Next question. Got to be one.
>> Yeah, I'm going back through the chat,
too. And by the way, completes um you
guys will get a little popup message
when you end Zoom and all the chat will
be as a text file, too, that you guys
can have there.
>> Excellent.
And then that other AI thing will will
uh have a lot of information including
the dialogue.
>> Did I also mention a way to protect the
windshield? Huh.
>> Well, we've lost a windshield on Route
66 when we did it last time. It was a
chip, but it still had to still had to
be fixed. Um, I'm not aware of a film
that goes over the windshield to protect
it from rocks and stuff.
>> Yeah, there is. But it's it's
problematic. It's not cheap. And we
probably won't be using wipers. But you
know what? If you're if you're really
worried about it, clear bra will work on
it, but you're not going to it's going
to be a bit opaque.
I I will say also that um you know I've
been an insurance guy for a million
years and you're driving on public
roads. You are driving at or below a
posted speed everywhere you go. Our
competition is built on timing and not
going fast. So you don't have to carry
special insurance to run great race as
everyone probably knows. You just have
to have regular regular coverage. So if
you get a windshield chip doing great
race, it shouldn't be any different to
get it fixed per your normal insurance
rules if that if that would apply.
There's no exclusion for doing great
race because of
>> Yeah.
>> And it just happened, you know, it was
thrown up by a truck passing us on Old
Route 66.
>> It was a gravel truck. You know, what
are the chances?
>> Yeah. So I have a question. Everybody
should be aware that the race can be
hard on the car. You know, the part of
the endurance portion of this is what
the car has to go through. Do everything
you can to make sure that your car is
reliable and everything's like
windshield wiper blades. I change them
every year. I don't use them in
California. I use them on great race and
uh Springfield. Yeah, we're about we
could get some rain. But I will say that
we did go through Tukum Kerry, which is
on the race route this year. Couple of
years ago, we saw two tornadoes on the
ground and two 18-wheelers that were
blown over on their side. It would have
been on the race course. And the
director of competition will pull his
crews back into their cars if there's
lightning on the ground. But if it's
raining, we're still racing. And uh the
you could have a situation where a third
of the course is fighting the rain and
twothirds of the course it's sunny and
clear and that is luck of the draw.
>> Oh, welcome to great race.
>> Yeah, welcome to a great race.
>> Yeah, stories to tell.
>> I have two questions. The new 55 mph
speed, is that going to be on course and
entire warm-up and in transit times?
>> That's you, Brad. I can I can just tell
you that where this competition would
have gone up to 50, it could go up to 55
now. So, yes, it could be on a tire
warm-up calibration. It could be on a
transit. Could be on the clock. You can
expect that you should have a car
that'll go 55. Absolutely.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah.
>> For an hour straight if necessary.
>> Poor driver.
I did 50 all across South Dakota one
year. That was memorable.
>> Yeah.
>> Then 48 is another good one.
>> What is going to be the the maximum
distance before we can fuel?
>> That's generally Yeah, that's pretty
broken up. Um, you know, I'd say
100 miles would be on the outside. Um,
you know, the Hudson had a 20 gallon
tank and we probably got 12 miles per
gallon in the thing and never had a
problem. I I
>> Doesn't the Doesn't the uh regulations
say that you should have a range of 200
miles?
>> I think that's probably that's probably
fair. I would also say every time
there's an opportunity to get fuel, you
should top up. Why? Why?
>> If it's just a couple of gallons.
>> Yeah. even especially if you're going in
places like Route 66. If you have a car
that takes premium fuel, um we've been
in some situations where we go through a
little tiny town that they don't sell a
lot of a lot of high test and you may
get a load of weird watery fuel. Look,
it it happens. Um we carry octane
booster. We carry um you know, heat, you
know, the stuff that can separate water
from fuel. I mean, you really do need to
be sort of prepared for whatever may
happen in some of these um really out of
the way areas that we like to rally in.
So,
>> and we will be going into the southwest
where E10 is your only choice. If you
have a car that likes to vapor lock on
ethanol,
uh deal with that now because everything
from Arizona
uh in will be E10.
on a hot weather.
>> Yeah. Wrap your fuel lines in, you know,
there's a lot of heat resistant foil
sort of stuff. Um, keep everything cool
off your exhaust manifolds where
possible. Keep yourself cool. Uh, block
your heat from getting in the car if you
want to, if there's some special way to
do it. I I will tell you and I've raced
in a lot of different types of cars and
points if you have a points distributor.
Um if you've got a pronics, carry
another one of those little doohickeys
with you because they fail. I've seen it
happen more times than I can count and I
run them. I like them. And a coil. um
carry a coil because um you would not
believe how many times I or a lot of
other people have had a coil go and for
the first few miles
>> last day on the last leg.
>> Yeah. And you're chasing is that a fuel
problem? Is that an ignition problem?
You don't really know for a few minutes
and it adds a lot of self-doubt. Just
bring a coil for your car and throw it
in. And uh I again I've seen that solve
a lot of problems.
>> You're right.
>> But you got to know your car. know your
equipment. Put hund put a few hundred
miles on it before you hit the course.
Um, torture test it.
>> Practice driving the speed and holding
the speed.
>> And doing your performance chart will
give you a time to ring out the car as
well. And also,
>> yeah, don't show up without one. Don't
expect someone to just hand you one
because your car is like theirs.
thing I would add is that because of the
55 mph minimum speed this year, if
you've got a Model A Ford, I would go
out and run it on a hill and see if you
can hold 50 or 55 on a grade. And if you
can't, you need to figure out what speed
you can hold, which might be 10% down,
so you can calculate how much you have
to make up on the other side. The uh
every car is different. And every car
has a different performance capability.
Some cars are geared real low, which
that won't be a problem. Some cars have
overdrive, which you may or may not
need. Sometimes that doesn't help you at
all. Uh, got to know your car. More you
drive it, the more you'll know.
>> Yeah. a non-synchronized transmission.
If you're running a car with a very
basic three-speed or so, um you may be
holding a perfect gear to hold yourself
down a perfect speed down a hill and to
keep yourself off the brakes, but as
soon as you there may be something else
that changes at the next instruction or
over the next hill, uh you may not be
able to go down another gear to slow to
go up. You just have to know what's
going on. The the Hudson's that way. If
I'm I'm committed, if I put a lot of
load on that, I've got to I've got to be
ready for whatever I think the next
thing's going to be. And you're the
driver is always looking at the speed
and looking at the road ahead, trying to
figure out and anticipate what they may
need while the navigator is doing the
work on the clipboard. And the
>> if you're a driver of a lowowered car
and you see a hill coming up, don't wait
till you hit the hill before you hit the
gas,
>> right?
>> Start speeding up before you get to that
hill.
Uh, the question came up. Are Brandon's
performance charts different? Well,
they're not made. You make them from his
spreadsheet.
>> Individual.
>> People try to use other people's
performance charts. If you find a car
that's similar to yours, the performance
chart may be in the ballpark. But
drivers drive differently. Cars run
differently. Every performance chart
reflects both the driver's techniques
and what that particular car can do.
That's that's why we encourage you to go
out and make your own performance chart.
Otherwise, if you get to the race and
you don't have a performance chart, you
have to borrow somebody else's, you will
not do well.
>> But Brandon has created a tool. So, what
he's done is he's given you the
structure within an Excel spreadsheet
that if you go out and you run those
different speeds like we explained, the
the driving straight through at speed
and then starting from a stop or going
to a stop put and and finding what those
those numbers are, each one of those
speeds, then you can input them into
Brandon's tool and that will create the
chart for you. So, you put in all of the
the inputs that you have gathered and
then it will generate your actual chart
and you'll just print it out, but you've
got to do the work to come up with those
numbers to put in the tool.
This is a tool I think that he just
created this last year. So, it it it I I
looked over it. It's it's fabulous. So,
I highly recommend it.
What else we got out there?
We got 53 people that are sitting going
are fried, the smoke coming out of here.
>> It's 10:30 at night.
>> I don't know what we do at night now. Uh
we all go in the parking lot and we
drink beer and we fix each other's cars.
It's really probably it could be the
most fun that you have all day. It
depends on what the weather's been.
>> Do the decals first so they're not
crooked.
>> We we we call it therapy. So, it's like,
okay, do you want white therapy tonight
or do you want red therapy?
>> That's right.
>> Red, please.
>> We have changed engines and cars in the
parking lot. We have changed
>> transmissions.
>> We everybody and and I will tell you,
this community pitches in. So, if you've
got a problem and you need an axle or a
U-jint or a whatever, if somebody has
one, they're going to help. They're
going to help you. And quite frankly,
it's it's the most fun part of of all of
this over the years is the friends that
you make um in the parking lot
commiserating about what what a disaster
it was or how great it was as you're all
trying to help each other get ready for
that next day. It um there's
>> or you'll come into the game at the end
of the night and you'll announce we have
a you know 1954 Packard and we just lost
our starter. Does anybody have a starter
for a 1954 Packard? And there will be a
guy in the crowd that says, "I've got
one in my garage. I'll bring it in or or
bring it over to my to my garage and
I'll put it in for you."
>> Kate Gerardo.
>> Amazing what what you will find at the
finish gate at the uh
>> There was a guy that had automotive
electric shop within two blocks of the
place. All we had to do was push start
the car to get it up to his shop. He
rewound the starter while we were there
and the car was ready to go the next
morning.
>> Yeah, it it's a great community and
you're all you're all car people. You're
all interested in this in this hobby or
you wouldn't be here and uh you've
probably experienced this in other ways
before you got here. It It's no
different. It's amazing. I see I saw a
message about how many rookies. We
covered that earlier, but it's about 50
rookie teams. So, 100 um people and we
have um
>> 100 new family members,
>> 156 teams or something like that at the
moment,
>> which is a lot.
>> It's a lot.
>> It's a lot. Typically, by this time,
we'll have a lot of people that have
said, "Oh, my car is not going to make
it." Or, "Hey, push me to next year."
Route 66 has been the uh the siren call
off in the distance, and nobody's
nobody's getting out of it. So, um, it's
really exciting. We have a very, very
cool field.
>> It's very, very cool.
>> And we're likely to run into other tour
groups where we're on Route 66. That
time of year, people will travel from
foreign countries and rent
Harley-Davidsons to ride up Route 66 in
black leathers in the middle of summer.
And, you know, chances are,
>> you think we're crazy.
>> Yeah. Chances are pretty good we'll run
across a few of those guys, too. you
know, be a a Ferrari that stopped in the
side of the road overheating and we'll
pass him in our study baker and smile
and wave and honk at him. You know, that
kind of thing. There's going to be all
kinds of things going on on Route 66
this year.
>> You're going to make memories. You'll
have lots of great stories.
>> Yeah, it's it's the best. All right.
Well, look, it's 9:30 Eastern time
anyway. My time. We're down to 27 or 28
people. Are there any other questions?
>> I'm still seeing 47 up there.
So 29
>> 46.
>> Yeah.
>> People love listening to us. I don't
know why.
>> Well, they may have fallen asleep.
>> That's true. All right. Go home. Go
home.
>> Oh, I see. That was that was in the
chat. My apologies. Yeah. There could be
people that are just embarrassed to ask
their question in front of other people.
>> I'll wait till everybody else drops off
and then I'll ask.
>> Yeah. Yeah. We We're around. You have
>> what happens if you have to go to the
bathroom and it isn't on the chart.
>> Well, I can explain that.
>> You go very quickly.
>> Old guys, I've I've learned that there
is special equipment for older folks who
might have a incontinence issue during
the race.
>> I found a system that works well for me.
I know a couple of other drivers have
got systems that work well for them.
Trucker's friends and those kinds of
things. Worst case, the navigator has a
stopwatch and it's like, "Okay, we're
pulling over. Run over. There's a tree.
>> You do what you have to do.
>> All right, we're down to time
allowances. Let's go.
>> No time.
>> You can't file that, but you should be
able to,
>> but you should be able to make it up."
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, guys. Well, this has been fun.
Thank you for all of you who have stuck
with us and and listened to us trying to
stumble through everything. You don't
learn it all at once. We are still
learning things after
>> 25 years.
>> 25 years we've been doing this now. We
started out thinking this would be a
oneanddone deal and it didn't work out
that way. So, um, yeah, just come into
it with the attitude that we're going to
have fun. We're going to learn how to do
it and we're going to just get out there
and get after it. You know, it it it'll
be interesting. There's always stories
to come back with.
>> And thanks for the veterans that that
logged on that have done this before.
just um we appreciate your confidence
and and your support.
>> Yes, very much so.
>> Great. Thank you everyone. Open
dialogue. Anybody has questions,
continue to feed them in to uh Steve and
Janet or through the website or the
blogs. Any which way we could answer
questions for her, we're we're all happy
to.
>> Right.
>> All right, Janet. We will see you in one
Springfield or